[Music]
as you can tell
by my vintage thrasher shirt i can't
even
i have my bathroom my my
my stutter's gotten worse as i get older
we have tony hawk on the show as you can
tell about my speech impediment
i mean i was stuttering a lot around all
the boarded over my tongue wait what
i was going to say something
inappropriate about a man ollying on me
and i'm not going to
anymore well i couldn't even think of
what the name of what was it before it
was
stuttering now we know i have one okay
up top banter
okay but i just wanted everyone to know
i am absolutely pandering to whoever's
watching this this is my
favorite thrasher sweatshirt uh that
i'm obsessed with it and i was gonna
wear it for the interview and then i
chickened out and got embarrassed
uh because like what kind of loser it's
like here's my third you're doing
like okay i feel like i've got the same
kind of talks about it now and i
even bought a pair of vintage air walks
to wear to pretend that i i mean i do
fully buy costumes to wear when certain
guests come in and then i like
you know i said what kind of loser these
are my shoes i bought
and then yeah that's right and then i
ordered these on
uh ebay yeah this was ebay not etsy for
once and i was going to wear these these
you think i'm so cool
and not only did i back out at the last
minute see the air walking they were
cool too
they're super cool but i also they i
bought them in um the wrong size these
are size eight i thought there was a
they were a men's egg so now they're
just collectibles
we have a very exciting episode i mean
it's already been our mind-bending
thrill ride
but uh thank you guys for tuning in to
tony hawk he is often referred to as the
goat
of skateboarding um already a tangent
why is it
i know it means greatest of all time but
if someone is the greatest of all time
can't you take a second out of your day
to just say the complete phrase
and not degrade them into being a goat
which is truly the least impressive
animal
you're the goat i don't think like
awesome i think like they jump on people
in yoga on instagram
so they're business people
branding always bringing i'm just saying
i don't like i don't like go he's the
goat he's
like that's what everybody says now i'm
like can you just say greatest of all
time are you that busy
he's a jellyfish are you are you that
busy that you need to abbreviate it i
don't know i just think it's
disrespectful it's cool
also tony hawk something that's i think
really
um kind of profound about this interview
is we talked a lot about the fact that
that in addition to being the greatest
of all time i have time to say it
tony hawk is like has an incredible
business brain like he
he built this massive video game empire
obviously called tony hawk pro skater i
just i love people that are
super creative have an athletic skill
are known for that but then they're also
able to have a business brain which
usually we're stereotyped to not be
good at numbers or being be able to talk
to the adults you know we always have to
sit at the kids table it's
it's just cool because i just so many
artists athletes
you know they never got to learn or they
don't like it or
we're just treated like children yeah
which honestly makes a lot of sense for
group people who throw fit so they don't
have their special little bowl of purple
skittles
it's weird that you guys have that
you're labeled like that huh us
creatives we're like
why do people think we're crazy and
we're crying over this is not the water
i drink
i can only show up if you have my three
pillows
i do need three pillows i need a nap i
need i need to pick
what is that a diggity because i sleep
with a pillow behind my head
a pillow over my face and then i have to
hold on to one like that's something i
sleep too so it's technically about me
okay i'm gonna say i do feel like you're
projecting a little bit
anyway tony hawk i'm obsessed with tony
hawk for so many reasons but i think
it's super cool that he shows that
you can elevate whatever you do into a
business right a lot of things we do we
can't do forever
and he built this video game i'm always
trying to think how can i
expand what i do to be a business that i
can just like
not have to tour if this all dries up
and goes away like
maybe one day i could be like a
therapist
oh do you think you could be a therapist
yes okay well i just i'm just i have
maybe
just a few reasons you might not be able
to test
i don't think that someone who buys
syrup in bulk should be allowed to give
advice on ocd
did you just attack my glitter maple
syrup addiction yeah
yeah i have this it has glitter in it
this is syrup
with glitter in it anyone who bought
just one is a
psychopath and how many did you buy nine
and how many have you used none
because i don't want to use it but if i
use it i won't have it anymore
it's called thinking ahead what if they
run out i'm just saying if you were a
therapist you would have these people in
a traumatic spiral in your office
you'd be like linking their ancestral
traumas like dracula or west virginia
a lot of people are from appalachia
google it
i'm from applebee's tony hawk i think
you didn't know rob was actually was it
because you were just
you were spending all your time thinking
of like reasons you're like think when
you think
when would i traumatized by a skateboard
when
i only have good memories about
skateboards my brand the brand
i have to somehow make myself the victim
in this scenario you're just sitting
there
like listening to tony talk about things
he loves the thing he enjoys most of the
entire life and you're like
interesting so there's no hurt around
this like
nothing weird you didn't want to have
sex with the skateboard the skateboard
didn't have sex with you did you have
sex with you did this skateboard have
sex with you
i think that skateboard is from west
virginia i think
there's a lot of trauma around these
wheels
speaking of whales which group are you
were you which which part of the bbb and
s's were you
bb bns bike boards blades and skates i
was a roller blader oh well i got these
hot little legs and i had very few
friends and i love storming out of a
fight but not as much as i like gliding
out of a fight
that is a power move it's gliding away
from a fight
i was um not as elegant with my roller
blading but i was a
very um somewhat infamous around the
town of philadelphia
town city you know the township so i
used a rollerblade
in philadelphia when i was in college
there every day i would rollerblade
uh with my walkman i had my cd in my
walkman
my now that's what i call music volume
the one with lady marmalade and
destiny's child somewhere between
10 and 78. honestly that is the coolest
superpower ever being able to tell
someone
the song with this on it and they know
that now that's what i call music but
like there's someone out there who
curated those who if you were to sit
next to them you could go like
which is the one that was like uh uh to
the to the left beyonce song and now
that's what i call
um the music volume four versus 72. and
then other people you're like which one
had um which one had uh the jlo waiting
for tonight's song on it they're like
i don't know i had real cds i didn't
have i didn't have this
this uh playlist you know it was from
the 90s it was like the cliff notes it
was like if you didn't really know
anything about music you would just like
hear all the ones
it was like it was like top 40 but you
could buy it it's like here's what you
need to know
here's what your friends are saying
anyway but i would ah so psycho
i would study while i was rollerblading
and i would
carry note cards with me so i would put
my walkman like
in the sports bra and then i would have
note cards with all the things i need to
study on it so i think about it and try
to memorize stuff while i was
rollerblading
never got hurt until i did and
i once slipped so hard i think it was on
like
walnut and set there's like a because
also philadelphia
i love you but it's cobblestone
street like some of the streets are
still little cobblestones like it's like
charming and adorable
if you have great health insurance but
not if you don't and i
fell like you know what have you ever
like skid
flown across the ground where you're
just like levitating and you just like
are
just going recently
i scratched from my ankle all the way up
to like the top of my knee
a giant so like no skin like you could
see skin on the ground type of thing it
was like um
that asphalt that has the little uh like
dimples in it
you know skin on the ground yeah you
shed your skin well no my skin that
whole top of my skin came off a little
snake
and uh and the next day i
had like a going-out thing to do i was
like going to the club or whatever and i
couldn't cancel it was the club
and i put on my were you in philadelphia
i was in college i was
19 20. oh i was like you were studying
and going to a club you know what i mean
it was probably like a bowling alley
whatever it was i was going out i had my
bb
black pants i had my diesel jeans that
were just for going out
you had on pants and jeans no i'm
telling you these are the
there's a difference between your going
out shirts and you're going out pants
and then your day pants i had my bb
handkerchief top and my
tube top which was just for going out
that was just for
you know the bowling alley and then i so
i put on my
diesel jeans i had to go to this thing
it was very important to me
uh and the scab the blood congealed
with the denim and i couldn't get them
off
and i had to cut them off my body at
like three in the morning
drunk on zima and i took i tried like
wet it i tried do all these things
so i just waited because i assumed it
was just gonna fall off like with the
scab or whatever
and so i had this patch of jean on my
leg
it's kind of punk rock actually but uh
then i'd go to the doctor a week later
because the scab
it had like enmeshed and then i had to
get it
removed you seemed fun i was functioning
do you know how hard it would have been
for me to find a michelle branch themed
skateboard
if you would just get into the etsy mix
with me i'm sure you could find one but
it's the 90s
i wanted to learn how to skateboard
purely for just the fantasy of it
the fantasy of going to the emergency
room yes i never been to a hospital
before
um you would honestly be surprised at
the amount of skills that i learned
just for the fantasy of it like typing
timing we had to type in high school at
a class like it was a required class
and i was not at all motivated about the
grades i only wanted to type to be like
carrie bradshaw in sex in the city
i was over here like meanwhile across
town there was no town
is that you are you someone who lives in
the fantasy i live in the fantasies i
saw tim burton's
uh batman you could not tell me i was
not catwoman when i was little
the the the ruby tuesdays i don't know
the owner of ruby tuesdays he had a
couple
he had to come over to my mom and he was
like uh ma'am
is that your son on the salad bar i
crawled onto the salad bar
and as strangers were passing the salad
bar i was going i don't know about you
miss kitty but i'm feeling
so much yummier right now
cottage
pudding at the end was like put in the
cottage cheese at the end was like
oh yeah i was eating with the ladle just
fully just look at these people dead in
the eye
seven six years old some of that that
was my life so i love the fantasy did
you love the fantasies i did
i mine are just almost too embarrassing
to admit i mean i was more
with musicians i wanted to be lisa loeb
so bad when that song came out that i
would storm around
my house and just be like stomping and
like because she would just walk back
and forth down the hallway i can do that
i've got a hallway that's one thing i do
have
i don't necessarily have a giant ball to
do wrecking ball
dude the videos in the 90s you could do
them
they were that simple you know there was
no like cgi and all that stuff so i
would storm around my house
but this is actually very recent i i
want to say
six or five years ago um when i went
through a really bad breakup
i would recreate the robin video
dancing on my own or just call your
girlfriend right that the one where
she's
the moment she's in the warehouse and
it's one uncut first of all people need
to know that that video
robin uh call your girlfriend is one
take
do you know how hard that is to do it's
one take and i know how hard it is to do
when you're doing that
and i was doing i would walk backwards
you know how she like does in the video
oh i know very well
because me you know i got in trouble
when i worked at mac
because i used to perform that song in
the floor when she rolls around the
floor
i would just be rolling around the floor
customers all around they're like can
you please stop
doing that and i was like it's robin
like what do you what do you mean
were you like the person at uh your jobs
that was like trying to get fired
no i just knew that i was valuable and
they couldn't get rid of me there you go
either you have yeah either you want to
lose a job or you
just know what you i'm the fun one i was
like people like coming here
i remember in that show mash the guy
that wanted to get sent home and he just
would wear a dress all the time
it's a little before my time but i think
i've heard okay wow
do you remember mash i don't remember
the war
i just remember when i was a kid i'd be
like why is that character in a dress
and they'd be like oh he wants to get
sent home and i was like why would that
could be but nowadays
promotions they said that is our ceo
so we can look progressive
i don't know he's tony hawk is just the
coolest in this interview he's just
cooler than ever yeah we should go back
to skateboarding you're right oh
i think so i think so we could detour
all these people like tuning in to hear
tony hawk talk are like why are you guys
talking about makeup and lisa love
boner killer i want to be like tony hawk
so bad i thought it was so
if i could skate i was like i'll be the
coolest person live if i can skateboard
but then i found out that um he had that
playstation game and i could just be him
from the comfort of my beanbag chair
and i'm like work smarter not harder
i'm obsessed with this video game i mean
i can't play right now with my thumb
because it's been severed open and is it
deeply infected
um but i love his video game because
there's no like hookers that are getting
murdered
you don't have to sex traffic people you
have to get scurvy like in oregon trail
right oh no but you can't dress yourself
up in tony hawk's games
you need to build your character that
was the that was the moment
oh it was like mr potato head with yeah
it was like
yep button potato head i think that's
how you pitched it it was like what if
we had a game
where you're me but also you can be a
potato head
and just skateboard around and people
are like sold
keep making them i also he we talk about
his new podcast he has a podcast
called hawk versus wolf and no joke it's
truly one of my favorite podcasts even
before
we scheduled him on the pod because um i
can't really listen to everyone's
favorite podcast or comedy podcast and
that's awesome but they're all my
friends and i have to listen to them
complain about cancel culture enough
when i'm not listening to their podcast
so i
i love listening to really smart people
talk that are in
a different field than me because
but yeah also the podcast is super
specific in a way because i thought in
order to understand tony hawk's podcast
you're gonna have to know a lot of
granular stuff about skateboarding but
when you listen to it even if you know
nothing about skateboarding
it's so specific that it also becomes
universal everything's a metaphor it's
about triumph it's about grit
it's you know and when they talk about
it and when they talk about like i wish
i had just done that one thing that one
time it would have changed everything
you know it's just
it's really um uh it's really soothing
and
i think i get out of that podcast i
think what other people get out of
comedy podcasts
i also think it's really refreshing to
hear two men talk
about things other than chasing axe
wounds
or being on the hunt for strange it's
nice to hear
two grown men have an adult conversation
that doesn't involve
you know getting it wet getting that
whatever i don't know i love it i love
hearing
i love hearing men talk about things you
know they actually know about
it it doesn't happen a lot in podcasting
does it
we also talked a lot about feedback
public feedback which today manifests as
negative comments
and i think we've all been led to
believe that we're the first generation
that has ever had
any public feedback or negative comments
and we're these victims that all of a
sudden the internet is so toxic because
the negative comments
that's always happened and i've been
frustrated about it too where i'm like
i can't believe that like betty page
didn't have to deal with this because
she's obviously
you know my mentor and um he was talking
about how when he was
you know at the height of being you know
the goat
thrasher magazine like someone some
guest writer would write like negative
things about
him and the way he skates or the style
of skating or something like that so
it's like
oh my god there was always trolling and
it's actually
in a way a little bit better now because
if you have a negative comment you can
delete it now no one will see it but if
you don't like what was written about
you in thrasher magazine you can't just
like throw away every copy
you know you have to cut it out and glue
it on your wall i think that was like a
dart set i think it's like a different
level of like
imagine because also everyone was
reading it and all the people in your
community read it you know it was
imagine if there's a comedy magazine
with negative con and every comedian
comedians aren't reading my negative
comments they're leaving them
um so it's just like it was really um
it was just really cool to talk to
someone who was at the top of their game
who was like a hero
this untouchable hero and then you hear
him now and he was going through that he
was going through
all the negative comments stuff and he
you know handled it with grace in class
and even today
wasn't talking shit about anybody he was
just like
rose above it rose above it and it was
just kind of refreshing just to hear
like oh
negative feedback trolls like this has
always existed it just looked different
it was just in different iterations
it's i mean we used to um remember in
school when you'd sign
casts that was like the first comment
section
we've had this basically i just break my
arms just for friends
i think it's important to say to
everybody watching this listening to
this
that if you are a hardcore skate fan and
have never listened to this podcast
before and are just listening for tony
hawk
uh do not worry it's not going to be me
being like what says
what's an ollie flip like what's a
turnaround in the pool or whatever
i have one of my best friends in the
world kevin christie
brilliant comedian uh he was on an actor
on he was on masters of sex he's a
brilliant brilliant artist he's
incredible he just had his paintings on
display
in new york whatever he's like has real
exhibits he's like a
very like real exhibit like yeah exactly
and um and he knows i mean he has an
encyclopedic knowledge about
skate history the i mean the most
obscure of obscure and he actually has a
show
called sticker album where he just goes
through
and gets granular about a certain
skateboard sticker
like really interesting it's it's
actually fascinating and
it was really cool to watch him uh
come show tony hawk some of the stickers
and kind of like blow tony's mind he's
like whoa i haven't seen one of those
like
it's really cool to watch whether you
know a lot about skating or not
it doesn't matter it was just it was
really cool to see such a specific
conversation
and and them so bonded and the
connection is really cool to watch yeah
yeah so anybody listening
if you're not a fan of me don't panic uh
it's really fascinating and i i made
sure i didn't ask
all the questions and i don't even be
there so you lucked out
um so i asked him questions about life
and philosophy
and marriage and parenting emily even
said uh
that she didn't know anything about
skateboarding and she still doesn't and
she was like this is one of my favorite
episodes and i don't know anything about
skateboarding so it's cool i think on a
lot of levels i'm really proud of it i'm
gonna go out i'm gonna grab a limb here
and i'm gonna say that the conversation
that we had when kevin christie came in
with all the stickers
might be the most comprehensive
conversation
slash discussion about skateboarding
history ever
at least recorded and have we done a lot
of research into this
no no but why didn't i believe it too
why are you i'm sorry
this is the q anon network you don't
research anything you know what in a
couple of years we'll
we'll start when do any podcast host
research anything they say you're taking
the fun out of it
the whole point of a podcast you just
say something and then you'll find out
in the comments later if you're a racist
or not oh
okay in that case well let's shut up
because
everyone wants to get tony hawk we have
a couple announcements
to get out of the way the great taylor
tomlinson
myself and uh one benton ray are going
to be in reno
this friday like in two days july 23rd
we're gonna be at the grand
sierra resort come see how grand it is
it's your last chance to see this very
odd co-headlining
thing i mean yeah it was a strange time
we both yeah fun taylor and i
i love her she's like a sister to me and
during the pandemic we're like let's do
shows together
outside and this was one that just kept
getting cancelled and canceled now we're
like
this is weird kind of weird that you
know it's like people love it it's like
it's like having um
a uh vacation planned and then you break
up with the person you're like should we
still go even though we're broken up
it's not refundable it's almost like
that
why would you do that i'm just saying
i've done that before i'm like ah let me
just wait to break up with this person
i know he cheated but we have this room
booked and it's not it's not refundable
like
trust me um what should we do in reno
though should we do other stuff
i think we should solve crimes okay i
heard they have some crimes and
i have little knowledge uh-huh
and no leads but you got moxie but i got
money and that's all that matters and
you're i got determination
and i know the sunset's in the west and
benton you guys might
i mean if you do need a couple citizens
arrests made
we're your guy because i would love to
do a citizen's order because
i do it all the time for something like
i want you to be like
hey you're not putting that buggy back
where it goes citizen's arrest
we're also going to come do some lols
for you
in sin city herself las vegas
on august 7th at the mirage you know
they told me that most of the
tickets that are sold in vegas are
the day of the day up yeah that makes
sense people are just driving
you don't even know it's real or not
you're like no but it's like a lot of it
is the week of
because they just see your photo places
and like they just wasted and they're
like oh look
joan rivers is here great and it's me is
that when he comes i wonder if she sets
herself on fire
i'm very excited because you know what
they say what happens in vegas
gets seen at the urgent care in vegas
that is true
uh and then the touch me tour as you
guys know because i have to post about
it
constantly to the point of being
obnoxious uh first like of the touch me
tour is approaching
i'm gonna be in very many cities you
guys keep asking me how to buy tickets
i don't know if you're amish i don't
know if you're
like i don't know is it can mormon
people have you don't want to touch us
that bad
i don't it's just it's how do i get
tickets like oh you bring your
uh brick of gold to the uh ticketing
office like how do you think
first you're going to find a bridge
under it there'll be a troll
he'll have a riddle if you can enter
that riddle
yeah people are like people like i guess
i just have to wait outside to find a
scalper to buy tickets from i'm like
it's just
if you know my name just put a dot com
on the end of it and
all the information is laid out for ya
uh point a vedra point
ponte pont vedra maybe part of the
reason that um
everyone's so confused about where i'm
going to be is because i can't pronounce
any of the cities
they're like where are you going to be
ponte vadra
i'm going to be at pointy virta port
verda
florida point what is it ponte
pa i'm really bad at things like that
she's going to be at pontoon veranda
concert hall uh at the ponte vedra
concert hall on september 10th september
10th
and i know what you guys are thinking
you floridians out there that find jesus
in your toast every morning
this is a friday night how am i supposed
to start binge drinking for saturday's
jacksonville jaguars games if i'm at
whitney's show
laughing it up peeing my ponte loans
well
maybe my pontes
that's not the only way i'm going to
remember it now my ponte verdes
you may not be able to see the jaguars
but you can come see this cougar
with a case of june shine in my green
room fridge instead
please come support uh if nothing else
because i'm gonna need some emotional
support because the next night we're in
clearwater florida home of scientology
and you and you know i mean i i am
shocked i'm not in scientology
i you know i love an expensive cult yeah
me i'm shocked i'm not in there either
because i love running lives
i mean i spent years in soul cycle i
mean i have spent so much money on
bullshit i am shocked that scientology
has not got their hooks in me yet i
always worry i'm like am i not famous
enough how come they're not no they're
just like we don't want that they're
like
she has too many questions and also
they're very anti-psychiatry i think and
i
am a psychiatrist basically a licensed
pretty sure humor's on high on the list
of uh i don't know
i don't know about that they do have
great brunch um
anyway i'm doing two shows there
scientologists you are welcome uh
i we will welcome you wholeheartedly i
know a lot of people in hollywood don't
like you
i don't judge i've made a lot of bad
decisions too two whole shows
we are doing two shows saturday
september
11th uh never forget the tickets are
available
at whitneycummings.com for the capitol
theater
in clearwater i've also been told that
this is the greater tampa area if you
want to drive
here from other places greater tampa
area
yeah and also make a better september
11th memory
this is a what you want to have your
memory come to this show
when you're done celebrating come over
yeah uh do you want to see another
tragedy
come to clearwater florida we have a
pack of these you know no one's gonna
see this brick house fall if i can find
a bag no can't say that
i'm gonna lift
[Laughter]
i also love that you had your drink
ready for when you killed whatever that
joke was oh no i just thought of that
but that's comedians though comedians we
we have our drink ready if you ever
watch a comedian on stage live which you
will see very soon
in clear water oh yeah that's me when
i'm trying like what's my next show when
you're so
sure something's gonna kill that you're
like and i'll drink to that
i have to wait for these claps to be
what am i gonna do so boring comedians
are the only people in the world
that when something is going good for
them they're still like i need i want to
talk right now
like like yeah can you laugh faster i'm
trying to try it
you have to you guys i haven't talked in
10 seconds can you stop clapping please
but if you don't clap it's like what's
wrong with you guys the only job in the
world where you're like
no no i was i have more things to say
like no we like it
yeah but also please laugh i know and
then when they yell i love you like
security removes them
yeah i love you get them out get them
out of here right now what do you think
about it
i know you really comedian's mental
disorder people really need to remember
this when they're listening to comedians
on podcasts because that's it is
ubiquitous
these days it's there's we're miserable
either way
cancel culture if people weren't trying
to cancel us people who go how come no
one's offended by that joke it was
supposed to be a defensive joke yeah
like why aren't they mad about it like
you know i know
clowns we want you to laugh and also be
a little scared no we're you cannot win
with us
either way uh which is why
so many people want to marry me the
weekend after
ow oh fuck sorry we're gonna get
demonetized
i you guys i do have this giant gash in
my finger and i gesticulate so much and
this is a vintage
you have a cut in your finger did you
guys know
i but i need people to understand this
is a
vintage vintage thrasher hoodie that i
will not put in the dryer i hang dry it
so it's like
it's like sandpapery and i just hit my
open wound on it and i get no scissors
that's a good sale this this hoodie
is sandpapery i'm not sure
it's rough i'm bleeding right now
can we please get to the next city that
i don't know how to yeah the weekend
after
clearwater we're going to where you go
tell me miami
okay that was okay i am okay that was
great
september 18th we're in oklahoma but
just know the buffalo run casino where
we're performing uh is very close to
joplin
missouri tulsa oklahoma where
a lot of my aunts live who disown me
maybe they'll come to the show
now they've got to move so
how about you guys come to the show even
if you're not super close by
hop in one of the many cars parked on
your lawn
and drive your lawnmower there
all my aunts have like four cars on
their lawn you know oklahoma it's like a
thing
that's lawn decoration it's like a
museum it's an automotive museum of all
the cars they've ever driven 20
i'll show you these cars this is where
the grasshopper this one's the kia soul
i can't move this this is where we keep
the ladybugs uh this is ladybug's house
so specific
that's some shit i would do that is so
exciting well no i had it i have like
no that's ladybug i have a trash can
that's upside down that i really need to
use but i opened it and there were like
lizards underneath it living in and i
was like oh i guess that's your house
now oh my god you're home yeah you
squatted
and you're that's your house i'm so
sorry they'll put you right back in
sorry um then what we're going to
another city
whose name i if i pronounce it i'm going
to get in so much trouble because i was
just told
that you can't pronounce this the way
that i normally do
sa luis obispo
i love this place it is gorgeous and i
just learned that people there just say
slow
slow california how how do why do you
how do you pronounce it get in trouble
because okay so russell brand i guess
went to saw luia bispo once and called
it solo e
they don't like that okay russell brand
okay feels like we're setting him up for
failure with the accent
okay okay you guys are making impossible
standards here i just
got a very aggressive dm that i'm not
pronouncing this right and i don't want
to disrespect
like somebody's personality is based
around where they live
we're gonna be playing the fremont
theater on september 24th
um benton didn't you say that it wasn't
the happiest city in america
it was voted no when we get there we'll
go over
that you want to see a dark cloud coming
that's us it's funny to me because
they're like this is the happiest city i
guess it was like voted and some pole or
something but they're also a huge wine
country town i mean their wine is their
thing
that's why they're so slow who
votes on the happiest city in america
you know who votes on something like
that happy people
yeah bored people yeah yeah that's a
really good point if you want to add if
you were asking if you asked
what's the happy city of maryland i'd be
like none of them the rent is so
expensive minimum wage where
i know imagine someone going
door-to-door being like are you happy in
the city
i'd be like you why are you knocking on
my door until someone knocked on my door
to ask me it
until you threaten whose study was this
like who what
organizations nobody else cares about
who's happy
then on october 1 i will be in
another city god we are only playing
cities that are really tongue twisters
this is not good for two people with
dyslexia
and reach and speech impediments
on october one uh we will be at
machan tuckett connecticut mashintucket
mashentucket marsha marsha marsh marsha
playing the fox theater at foxwoods
resort and casino
uh if you are from rhode island if
you're from connecticut we are also
going to
do the ridge field playhouse that's in
connecticut somewhere too but what i
don't know what are you called what are
they called if you're a connecticutter a
kinetic cutter
i'm a kinetic cutter in high school
cutter
also the foxwoods has a waterfall in the
lobby
it is a giant casino that is gorgeous it
is like
narnia there's a big waterfall so benton
and i are going to recreate the tlc
waterfalls video
in the lobby and just as as much as we
can until they
ask us to yeah until we drowned
get your tickets quick you know what i
think the opposite vibe of connecticut
is
canada cutter anywhere else milwaukee
milwaukee what a wild name it's just
such a great name
i'm gonna come i'm gonna eat some cheese
curds is that what they do cheese
curdles
can we eat some yummy mulch i'm gonna
come
eat that delicious mold on november
4th in true wisconsin form i will be
playing
a lovely venue called the pa ha pabst
theater patch blue ribbon
pops blue ribbon i love hats blue
ribbons that's
pat's pep pabst i carve i call her petey
um i love her drink with a straw i
am such a i am a because it's got made
like a weird comeback with hipsters too
now
oh yeah that's how i found out about it
yeah people i didn't like were drinking
and i said
i'm gonna take this over i'm gonna fix
this problem
our show at the borgata in atlantic city
november 6 is sold out we're a bunch of
sellouts benton
yuck gross but if you could not get
tickets in time for the atlantic city
show um it's a very close drive to go to
foxwoods on october 1st the wilbur
in boston on october 2nd we are doing
two shows there
and just fyi i need to go back and have
good shows
in boston because the last time i was
there i had a great set
and right at the freaking end i was
doing a sports joke about
um patriots fans because patriots fans
are so intense and i've dated a couple
patriots fans and it is a lifestyle
and a job as at the same time and
i i said something because patriots fans
when they watch games they wear jerseys
like they wear the jersey and in their
brains
it's like they truly feel like they
could get drafted at any moment
at 45 years old like every time the
phone rings they think it's bill
belichick calling to be like
hey dude we got a guy down we need you
saw you in that lazy boy
looking pretty good heard you had some
big opinions
and about how i dated this guy who was a
patriots fan
and for whatever reason every time i
came in
and sat on the arm of the couch because
i could only pop in out because i was
working on something at the time so i'd
pop in
pop out for whatever reason whenever i
sat on this part of the couch
they would win and there's a lot of
superstition and
i wore this shirt they won last time i
whatever they think they're like beaming
they think that
something straight boy astrology yeah
that's really funny and so we broke up
a year later it's football season again
and he called me
every year every year it's an annual
thing oh my god
he calls me up and he's like i know this
is awkward he was very sheepish in his
voice he was like
the patriots are playing tonight could
you come sit on the couch
just for a couple hours hey
i know this is awkward but can you come
spit in my lap
because that seems to be like the thing
you should people just lying they're
just making things up can we just make
out
can you just come back over here and let
me put
uh myself inside you just it's only for
the pain it's just kind of a thing
on your titties let's get married i need
the patriots to win
um anyway so the point is i said the
boston patriots
i was like is the boss and then everyone
was like everyone started groaning
and that is like a sin wait what are
they they're the new england patriots oh
i said the boss come see me get drafted
and then we're going to be at ridgefield
connecticut
october 8th we're doing two shows we
have a check a second show
trying out a little bird i guess i'm
just sean connery now
come see me redeem myself
in boston and then come to the
ridgefield playhouse it's i
kind of want to shoot a special there
but maybe i'll do it in one of my
favorite
favi cities on the planet i'm just gonna
start leaning into my babies all my
stutters i'm just gonna turn into words
i can't stop anymore i'm just doing it
uh seattle we are sold out at the
neptune theater that is
surreal december 4th we are adding a
show tickets go on sale
for the late show uh now they're on sale
now
go get them so says this these words
that i'm reading but just fyi
if you texted me on community you would
have been the first to know about this
and i wouldn't have to do these long
announcements where i hit my thumb
against myself and re-traumatize and
reopen it again and get it infected so
can you please
just text me i'm begging you i send
secret photos every now and then that i
don't put on social media
birthday every day you get a little
video for your birthday from meh we
should make some more too
they're like more photos more photos
you're going to send me more photos you
can also leave us voicemails at
818-538-9940 it would be super cool if
you guys like had something to say when
you called but here's zayn benton we
went through the voicemails the other
day
benton was not happy about that yeah
benjamin is disappointed
i am disappointed i'm disappointed if
you're gonna call you know you're
calling
you know you're calling have something
to say you can't just call me like
uh um uh uh
do you uh nice boobs and then hang the
phone up
okay i think that people probably would
perk up well
put it together perk up first and
foremost
anyways leave a voicemail eight one
eight five through eight nine nine four
zero
and nail it script it out yeah write it
down here's something if you want to ask
us questions we will answer them i want
to do a whole podcast episode where we
answer everybody's questions but we're
not getting questions we're getting
weird like drunk
you can't just breathe in the phone
we're not getting
clear cogent questions we're just
getting like cries for help yeah
rambling it's like it's just nonsense
and maybe speaking is not your thing
okay it's not our thing maybe you're not
great at it
so you can also email it emailed us see
this is why i don't need voicemails i
don't leave voicemails
email you can also okay let's do that
again so speaking is not your thing
but um you can also you know leave us uh
you can go to good for you fans at
gmo.com you can send us videos
songs you can type out your questions
you can ask for advice that way
you can leave comments concerned you can
send us pictures i love you guys
like subscribe hit the notification bell
so you might know if you haven't done it
right now you never well so i'm not
talking to you
the there's a ton of merch on the
website people are saying that a lot of
the merch is out but i
yes so you guys know some of the merch
is being phased out
for new merch we're not dillard's we
can't just stockpile this stuff forever
it sells out we gotta be new we're onto
the new thing the next thing
dylan's did pretty well
it is of the moment of the time but what
are people how do you think the
warehouse is
i don't i've been there it's huge but
it's full of other people's stuff too
okay but what can it be listen the point
is when the merch comes out get it
because it's gonna be gone okay that's
how the merch works that's how the
collection
goes and that and that is also we need
to i need dude this is very important
you guys need to like comment subscribe
and share but also please make sure that
on our youtube
and our instagrams you're hitting the
bell notification so you're getting
your we're getting your algorithm so the
i don't even know what that means that's
the little bell it looks like a bell
under the video i love you guys uh enjoy
tony hawk i am so proud of this one
and uh everybody pray that we can get
him back
so i can show him this cool thrasher
sweatshirt
he's not gonna watch them don't write
elephants just skateboards
big day on good for you it's a big day
this is a really big thank you
you know that i i you were one of the
first people i ever
wanted to have when i decided or gave in
to doing a podcast that's i would say i
gave in to it because i
i love podcasting i know you're so good
at it
yes i just i just listened to um a
couple episodes of your new podcast
um uh hawk and wolfe and i believe
we're very close and it's unfounded and
probably awkward and frankly um it's
just weird how close i think we are
after me listening to your podcast for
four hours no i believe that i believe
that we're close i just wanted to say
that because
the idea of podcasting like that i've
been so fraught about for so long and i
know you had radio show for so long and
like just the idea if we do this other
skill now
we're going to talk for three hours and
um
listening to your podcast to me was like
the best version of what podcasts are
capable of the idea of this guy
who's a hero who so few people get to
have access to
like this person that changed all of our
lives in such a big way and has been
ubiquitous and like um and so
influential the idea that like
i can just sit in my car and listen to
him shoot the shit for three hours oh
thank you
for free i think it was that both jason
and i
we've just had such a wealth of
experiences and at some point it was
like we should just get together and
tell our st you know shoot the shit and
and i know
that something he says is gonna trigger
something that i went through and then
what he went through and
and he you know we we had somewhat polar
opposite life experiences
but we both were pro skaters and our
lives did intersect quite a bit
so we have we've run the spectrum i have
so much to get to but i'm fascinated by
so skateboarding first i'd like to say
that my experience with it because i
feel like you probably do a lot of
interviews with people that know
so much and want to geek out and a lot
of people that know nothing you know
that are like what's it like to roller
skate that don't know it
yeah to me i'm from uh i grew up in dc
and the dc skate scene uh
in the at least for me i guess it was
early 90s that's how young i was like
you know
uh when i was exposed to it i know it
was going on before i was born
but that i very much attribute to why
i didn't go down the path of like pretty
serious drug
use because addiction runs in my family
and the
for whatever reason the graffiti and
skate scene that i was like messing
around in
uh was straight edge oh dc hardcore
yeah of course and the whole thing was
it's not cool to do drugs don't do drugs
and i was doing drugs and then i was
like
on your hands yeah dude three x's
everywhere mxpx like i was like that was
my shit and it was totally by
accident that i that the coolest scene
ever was glorifying don't do drugs
and i was like damn i was just got
access to all these drugs now i can't do
it like all right and
i just like you so my experience with
with skate is very much like
the the um the good kids that are like
straight and alert
it's totally and then just learning oh
if you want to do something really hard
and challenging that takes a lot of like
discipline and repetition and
uh the ability to focus like you don't
do drugs it's gonna you're not gonna be
able to do this
you know fly off this building on this
four-wheeled thing right and that got in
my brain early
um i think i i
my experience was more that i had
friends that were my age maybe a little
older and i
saw when they would get into partying
how much it affected their skating
and i only wanted to get good at skating
i only wanted to get better at skating
and i saw i was like i'm not doing that
because
i see how they you know kind of
they're starting to their skills are
fading and they're less interested in it
and that was
heartbreaking to me and i just thought i
i gotta
i gotta stay do this like this is my
thing can i ask this question
this question might come off weird but
i'm i'm really obsessed with the idea of
like
positive addictions like we all have
addictions sure i mean and just the idea
of like watching so many people when i
was younger
that could have whether you get to pick
your addiction or not but what i saw
people addicted to skating like oh i was
absolutely i still am do you have to be
in order to be
a pro skater maybe a bit but but maybe
not so
obsessively like i was i i think what
happened was
early on i learned a trick that no one
had done before
it was it was pretty my i mean it was it
really was
meaningless in the grand scheme of
things but to me it was like
i i did a thing that has never been done
and i created it and that buzz that i
felt
is what i've been chasing it's like the
first hit it's just all i've been
chasing the whole time and even today
i still learn some new tricks and i get
the same feeling when i land and i'm
like yes
but then i was listening to talk about
and this is so fascinating to me because
a lot of times people meet me after
stand-up shows or whatever and they're
like hey let's party and i'm like i'm
i'm not in like a festive fun mood
especially after i shoot specials
because i have so much resentment for
the amount of time it took to do that
like
when i get off stage after special i'm
just like fuck this job
fuck delta fuck hilton honors fuck
everyone who
like just because it's been eight months
of trying to get it perfect and when i
finally do get it perfect whatever that
means
it's not like yeah let's celebrate it's
like
it's a relief instead of a celebration
yeah i think well that
that labor can just get exhausting yeah
and then at some point the goal
is not even it feels like it's not even
worth it but it still has to be met
so because skateboarding is such a
singular i mean it's a very singular
sport
it is an idiot you know i mean i'm
obsessed with the difference between
like improv and stand up the difference
between like uh uh
what is it couples tennis and team
tennis
monogamous tennis doubles and regular
whatever
twins tennis what is the doublemin twins
is that who they made it for them
like the idea of being able to think
quickly involving another person
or i'm a lone wolf you know yeah and
stand up is very solitary like i will
find myself even when i'm like
moving around boxes in the house with my
boyfriend he's like do you need help i'm
like no no it's just better if i do all
of it
just trust me like i just that's even if
collaborating will make it faster my
brain
is just never wired that way for
whatever reason as a kid being alone a
lot whatever having to keep myself
entertained doing a podcast with someone
whose
brain is so singular you know is that
ever
i mean you guys have such amazing
chemistry is it ever like
um i well i mean
just in terms of my relationship with
jason he and i have known each other for
35 years or so and toured for a good
four or five solid years and had our own
show on siriusxm so we know each other
really well we know how to
how to have a good cadence um but i
think in terms of skating
i love skating with people yeah but i am
solely focused on my goal or my task in
hand or whatever i'm doing
it's just enjoyable to have that
camaraderie
and um and i wouldn't i wouldn't want it
any other way like i don't want to just
go to the ramp alone
right that kind of sucks you know
sometimes i do just because i'm like i
gotta work this out in my head and
maybe i'll go try it a few times but i
cannot get that fired up
yeah and i certainly am not gonna go
like do something brand new
all alone with no one around and then so
is that is
how big uh you know i was just asking
kevin about this like how big of a role
does the audience play in your number
one ability to focus
uh like having a good kind of pressure
like i was i was
um before we started i was telling him i
did yesterday this like
is it wake boarding what i did it was a
surfboard in the back of a boat yeah
wakeboard or wake surfing
wake surfing which is basically i just
all i had to do was like do a squat and
when the boat pulled forward i just had
to stand up and not overthink it
yeah and i overthink things and my brain
is always about like how do i entertain
these people not how do i do the best of
anyone that's ever done this because
i've never no one so how are you
how do you entertain someone when you're
you're trying to wakeboard your blood do
you just hold on to the rope regardless
of what happens
you just try to fall funny okay
everyone's like get up and i'm like all
i'm thinking about is how to fall funny
so that everybody laughs and i was like
no you have to pull it this way i'm like
no then i'd get up
i don't want to get up they've seen all
the falls go to youtube if you want to
watch a good vlog no one's going to see
me and be like whoa
like even at my bed she fell the best
that's the only place i can win here
i will never be the best wake surfer but
i could be the funniest
okay yeah do you know what i'm saying
yeah i see that no one's drafting me
like no one's
like interested like tropicana is not
calling me for a sunscreen
you also have to realize it's not that
they want a funny fall if they
if you're gonna fall and you're gonna
make it count it's got to be carnage
you have to hurt yourself you have to
hurt yourself that's when you're gonna
go viral or i've taken the biggest risk
yeah
and then the biggest uh slam that's it
yes that that's that's how you're going
to be successful in their eyes
okay so i can't be the funniest or the
best so okay there's no
no there's no place for me in
wakeboarding
but and i think more they just want to
see
they want to see a minor success on your
part to happen during their show right
that's all they care about
which is so interesting because i
realized a lot about my brain because
i had to go after you which following
tony hawk on a show about
being on a thing you have to stand
sideways on is really kind of daunting
so they're like oh yeah tony hawk was
just here i was like oh fuck you got
like why
i thought this was like celebrities that
knew nothing about sports play sports
like this is so embarrassing
but um but i get there and they were
telling me all about what you were doing
and how you were like trying to land a
trick and i was like oh so he showed up
and like tried i was just like goofing
off making camel toe jokes because we
were all in wetsuits and i was like oh
like you showed up to someone else's
show
but that's the but that's the flavor you
bring is that you get
you get to bring camel toe jokes i they
weren't looking that
they weren't looking from me yeah for
that
but do you ever feel this because i was
thinking about you and i was like oh my
god i get to do the show and just screw
around and jump into the water and like
not
and the only time i the only reason i
did stand up on that thing which
was kind of amazing i don't know if it
was just way easier than i thought it
was because i tend to overcomplicate
things
or if i did do a good job or something
but i only stood up so the host of the
show
was proud of himself and didn't feel
like the day was a disappointment that
was nice to you
but i didn't want to do a team i didn't
need to do it i don't care
like i didn't care like i was like i'm
up this is so fun the whole time i was
up i was just like i'm gonna fall soon
like you know what i'm saying there is
there's no when if you don't have the
skill for it
if you start doing something like that
you're just like which one of my knees
am i gonna lose today
like you just start like wrapping your
brain for your insurance plan i feel
like on the flip side of that if i go up
and try
to do improv or comedy maybe i will just
take a spectacular slam on stage
you know what that's entertainment you
know what here's what i'll say that
because you do have a nephew who's a
comedian yes right
have you ever tried no no i was not
i was not trying to no i know this is
okay you want to be a comedian so i i
what's this whole rig of my role about
you having a podcast let's make use
of me i know you're here but i do think
there's something about
you are a performer and entertainer the
most
when you're doing something alone
practicing alone versus having an
audience
and i do well let's put this way i enjoy
having audience um and definitely it
will give me
more incentive and fire me up more to
try riskier stuff or bigger tricks yeah
um and but i'd also do enjoy
not the solitude but just the the
mellowness of of having
the freedom to just bounce ideas and and
fall and
fall a lot to try to get to
some new technique or maneuver yeah but
when i'm in
sort of demo mode what i like to call it
i
stick with i kind of hit play the hits i
stick with the tricks i know i'm going
to make
for the crowd and then maybe
start to breach a little bit more risky
stuff and
some you know and if but if it's just a
crazy scene and they're just fired up
it's like all right we're this is the
day that's something big is gonna happen
um because i owe it to them i i'm
talking
like how are you ever able to forget
that you're tony hawk i mean no one else
will
so you i guess can't but are you ever
somewhere and like the
every time someone comes in it's like
added pressure to deliver on these
people's
expectations i'd say that the the
example of that is
if i go to a skate park because i i just
go to some skateboard
chaos i if i if we're traveling
definitely i want to
i want to check out the local parks and
if i go to a park
people expect me to perform magic they
expect to see
all the craziest moves they've seen me
do on tv or on video
um and i'm just happy to cruise around
some new terrain and check out what they
have
and a lot of times it's like why isn't
he flying
why won't he flip and spin and why isn't
he fell it's you know it's that kind of
thing
i i i you know i take it i
i take it in stride but at the same time
it is a little
frustrating because i'm like i'm sorry
i'm disappointing you yeah i'm just
trying to have fun
yeah like and there's also something
sort of interesting about that that
pressure and whether it makes you better
i think you know because skateboarding
from what i understand
and this is also what how you become
good as a stand-up but we
hide our attempts like there's something
so fascinating to me about i remember
when
when um i was just developing as sort of
a teenager and i was seeing
skateboarding on tv and all my you know
the crew i was in all they were doing
was watching these like skateboarding
they get one like vhs tape of a thing
and we just watch it over and over again
i was just trying to like
you know get a boyfriend but i did so i
was pretending that i knew what i was
looking at
but um but it's one of the only things
where you reveal
all of the for like a better word like
failures like here's all the attempts so
no one's like oh they just
you you have a record of how hard it was
to achieve
so it wasn't just this magical thing
yeah yeah
i we tend to leave that out for the most
part but uh
i like to show that process especially
now and with the freedom of doing it on
your own terms like
with social media and to show that
well basically the the difficulty factor
and the and the
the pain and the frustration you went
through to get there that's really more
what
i like to show i don't i don't wanna i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna bore people with
endless bails because some some tricks
that i've done
they've taken days weeks months to get
and i'm not gonna show the entire
process but a few spectacular
attempts is always fun have you ever
given up on one
yeah yeah i actually just gave up on one
a couple weeks ago
and then when you do that is it a very
conscious effort of like look
i could probably do this if i kept going
or
are you like there's a issue with the
trick in itself or are you like i'm just
don't need to do this anymore like
to myself i feel like it was a
combination of all three but but i
i think that the pardon me was like why
didn't i think of this
20 years ago because my body
and my timing would have been much more
in tune for this exact thing
and now it's just kind of slower
and that slow does not work for what i'm
trying to do
and so i think the other thing is i
never got so
close that i could taste it like i got
semi-closed
interesting but i never got to the point
where i was like that was it i had it
it was always like oh i almost had my
feet in the right place i'm obsessed
with your intuition because
it took me a long time to learn um that
especially when the stakes are kind of
high
if i'm going to do stand-up there are
times i'm like i'm just not feeling i
could go up there and absolutely say a
bunch of jokes that would do well but
i'm like something's
off and then i go on stage it would be
weird it wouldn't be as good i'd leave
feeling like shit
like someone important would be there
whatever i was listening to in an
interview talk about how you were
shooting a gap
an ad for gap yeah and you did this
crazy
yeah broke my elbow but you did it once
and they missed the trick
right and they said can you just do it
again and you knew something was off
um i just felt like i i got lucky that
first time
making it so well yeah and i was really
hyping myself up for that one
and then when i got it done it was like
yes that's it and then when they said we
didn't get it
in my head i was like i don't know if i
have that one again
so what so should you in your mind is it
is
like is that a mental game of oh i don't
have it because i'm saying i don't have
it if i just say i have it i will have
it like what's the psychology behind
going
i know i didn't let them into the
internal process
i i was at that moment in my life i
really
i needed the money i needed like i
needed that commercial pretty badly
uh in terms of paying my mortgage and so
i was just i was a worker bee like yes
that's what you need okay i'll do it
again no problem you know i was just
like here we go
and then i uh miscalculated a little bit
and broke my elbow um and
my first thought and this is pretty sad
but my first thought when i knew
that it was broken i knew i wasn't going
to be able to shoot anymore was
i hope they got something of me to use
in the commercial because back then you
didn't get paid a lot to do commercials
you got paid from residuals
because this was in 97 98
and so it was just like oh please i hope
they got something of me so i can get
residuals from this commercial
to pay for this fucking elbow from the
gap the gap in my fucking arm
and they did so uh it all worked out do
you have any like psychological tricks
of like you're having an off day or
you're having you know and you see
someone you know like
how do you keep your brain focused and i
i'm so easily distracted like the
tiniest thing can like sort of throw me
like
what is your like because obviously for
an athlete your caliber
you're just as much like your mental
fortitude and
sort of ability to calculate and keep
yourself under control
is how much of it would you say um it's
quite a bit i think that
when i am going to skate especially if
i'm just going well
i have different approaches because if
i'm just going to skate to practice just
sort of stay in tune
i have a few ideas maybe when i get
there that think oh maybe i should try
this trick again just to have it back in
the back in the arsenal
and i know right away when i start
skating
if i'm a little off and so how do you
know
um i can just tell with with how my
body's moving how i'm landing
um how my whatever my truck's not quite
on the way i thought it would be just
little things where it's just like okay
today is going to be
today is going to be a little more
effort and sometimes
i'll redirect what i was going to do
because of that
but if i go to the if i go up skate and
i feel like
i i'm in i'm on point everything's in
sync
then i'll redirect it to maybe today's
the day to try this thing maybe today's
the day to shoot something special
because
everything's clicking cracking yeah yeah
so i have it kind of both ways but
um sometimes and especially in front of
a crowd
if i get there and i just feel that
jitter and i know that it's affecting
how i skate
i'll immediately start with something
way harder
to sort of snap out of it interesting i
know that i don't know if that makes
sense or not but
but um it's it's helped me a few times
because
i instead of instead of getting in my
own head where it's like why can't you
just do what it's this is all basic
stuff why are you having such problems
with it
and that just sort of compounds itself
so then it's just like
i don't know try this thing that's
impossibly hard and i'll try that a
couple times and that snaps me out of it
and then is there do you have a positive
relationship with your inner critic like
i would imagine with
it i'm big on anxiety is helpful to me
fears
a lot of these unless they're
liabilities at this point but me beating
myself up going that wasn't good enough
like a lot of people like love yourself
i'm like
yeah i get yes sure but also me beating
myself
up is why i'm good at what i do i don't
want to stop my inner critic from
talking i don't want to stop
like that's how you get better like
what's your relationship when do you
listen when you're not
um i think when
i feel like i've exhausted every
approach every effort to something
and it's like that's it that's you've
given it everything you have
yeah just you just got to pull back um
i guess yeah but but it is it's still
kind of crushing and i definitely
you know i will drive home from skating
but other times i
if i just make it it's something maybe
it's not like it wasn't the
as high or as clean as i wanted it to be
i have to
i have to convince myself that that's
okay um yep that's pretty much what it
is
yeah and so it's like it's fine i'll do
that well also because
you know and i've and i've come to terms
with this only recently where it's like
you're fucking 53 it's fine you did it
you know that i get and
and that i almost was in denial of for
so long
that i just people just like oh man he's
so old and
he's still doing it and i'm just
thinking like i i still i can still do
it i don't know who cares how old i am
yeah and now i
i realize like yeah you're really old
and that's okay
you got it um this is something that is
fascinating to me and i know it's gonna
sound like a very odd question um first
of all what are you drinking so everyone
knows i'm drinking iced tea
just black blackberry tea i'm not sure
oh an iced tea that's good
yeah i just you asked what i wanted i
should i see no you asked for iced tea
but half tito's which is totally fine it
was just a weird order
it's like okay whatever it's tony hawk
you want a sad nyquil to it cool
punk rock um but uh but i have this this
sort of theory that like
if i if i'm standing at the comedy store
and
uh uh you know kevin and i are standing
there and a bunch of new comedians
coming down from a big new
faces sort of uh show that are obviously
all like
you know have a great 10 minutes they're
just starting whatever and then we're in
the hallway and we're like you know
let's introduce ourselves to all these
kids and just say like hey if you ever
need us
or need advice let us know right and 10
kids walk by
i have this theory that i it's out there
i could tell you who's going to make it
and who's not
just based on those conversations wow
and
because of the little tells you know the
way you do anything is kind of the way
you do everything it's like the kind of
person who asks me
you know too many questions and asked me
to do their job for them those are the
people who don't want to learn the hard
way or those
like the people that i think are going
to eclipse me are the ones they're like
i don't need to
fucking ask her advice like i forgot or
whatever it is the people that are just
like oh hi nice to meet you like i'm
going to be your equal one day or
i'm not going to ask you for advice
whatever it is
or the person that's like i don't want
to waste your time because i'm like oh
that person is insecure they're going to
work really hard and get go
is there anything if you just like walk
to a skate park in the middle of nowhere
like wherever when you're traveling can
you ever just like watch people for a
while like
younger people and just go i can i don't
even have to like watch that person very
long
yeah or i can just talk i just know that
person
is a style yeah well or or that they
will they have potential they
yeah i think it's more that i can see
people who
have this this confidence but also
a drive to keep pushing what they're
doing
and that's the sign where it's like oh
that guy's killing it but he keeps
trying harder stuff
nothing's good enough for this person
yeah um and
a tenacity that's like you cannot get
between an animal and their food type of
energy
right and and they're not doing it
because they're they're hoping that
you're gonna go notice them you know
that that's the other thing where it's
like
they think they're auditioning all the
time or they're always looking over
their shoulders you see that did you see
that
and that i can just tell that that's
going to not bode well for them later on
that's fascinating because it's number
one it's i love breaking down those
little instincts because
they're not they're going like i'm doing
this for me if i get famous and get
sponsorships great but this is between
me and this fucking board and this piece
of sidewalk yeah i feel like the success
is just incidental
um but but there are people who are out
there because they think it's their
ticket to famer fortune and
if they get any taste of that they lose
their motivation
that's fascinating which i've seen a lot
and then
do you i was just thinking about you and
like how you must move through the world
like
when you just walk around like is the
world just like a
giant skate park too like do you just
look at i just mean do you see things
you're like yeah look at that fucking
flight of stairs like
like comics we just look at things we're
like what's funny about this like
is anything not a ramp to you um
yeah i don't have that that skater eye
the way that you think because i grew up
skating at parks
and mostly skating pools and ramps and
all these designated areas
um but for sure there are things out in
the wild
architecture that's like how do we drop
in on that
how can we get access to that because
there are things that
also are in tune with the way i skate
that are perfect oh cool
um and so there are some key things you
know in in the world
uh big sculptures big iconic places
where
i think one day i could sneak in there
and do it that'd be pretty cool
that's a good idea that's like there's
this benjamin franklin statue in philly
that if i could just go before the
cleaning crew gets there
but um but in terms of street skating
the ones who really out there in the
streets that's all they do
yeah every handrail every ledge
everything is a potential
spot and clip they can get and what hour
do you think the traffic's not bad that
we can get here and shoot
i have so much to ask you and i'm do you
i'm i feel like i'm being really
calm and cool and collected i i i think
so i'm usually
really much more hyper than this i don't
even think i've interrupted him
is this shocking this is what it looks
like when i respect someone i'm sh i was
going to say that i'm
going to say that to you after the show
did i okay i
i'm notorious for interrupting and i
get excited and i it is my job to move
the conversation along
and make the guest as entertaining as
possible too i do get a lot of shit for
interrupting the guest but if your story
sucks i'm gonna
stop him then then i'm going to take
that as a comment i know yes
this is okay fair i'm just as surprised
as you are i want to hear every one of
his answers
oh thank you so um i look at the great
legends of any um sport
field say actors musicians and um
there's that is that
flu bear i'm gonna i'm gonna butcher
this um the flu bear quote be unexciting
in your personal life so you can be
violent and take risks in your
professional life
like you are someone that seems like you
have no drama in your personal life
so that you because i mean will ferrell
steve curl all these guys where
everyone's like oh they just constantly
every time you see them they're killing
they're focused
everything they do successful they're
not wasting a lot of time in their
personal life
dealing with old invisible wounds and
just draining themselves like
was that ever a conscious effort of like
in order to be a great skater i have to
just like put all my energy into it or
was it just a coincidence that you
um i've never seen a person
i've never really parsed it like people
who's destroyed their professional i
think for sure and and
yeah definitely i had enough chaos in my
personal life just in terms of
relationships and things but never
really going off the rails
um and i do feel like skateboarding
always kept me focused it always kept me
centered
and that was what i could always fall
back on right
no matter what um and so sometimes
that is my meditation i mean always
that's my meditation
because i'd like i'm like because i
think this is important because a lot of
people like why am i getting what i want
i've been working for three hours and i
don't have the thing or i've been
writing for two years and i
i don't have what i want with this stat
and i'm like well what else is going on
when you're writing are you distracted
by that person that's the malignant
narcissist you're dating are you
distracted by that
you know toxic like what are the
distractions in your life that
when you do need to because the amount
of i guess flow i don't know if
this is like that in the amount of like
how present you have to be when you're
doing that
is a i think part of the reason that i
love doing stand up so much
and is that when i'm on stage whether
i'm killing bombing
being heckled worst show my life back to
my life i can't be anywhere else
it's the only time my brain is in one
putting one foot in front of the other
yeah i think i agree with that
uh if i do when i'm when i do go to
skate
um everything's gone and
once i stop it's like check my phone
yeah it all comes flooding in again and
then my mind is spinning out but um for
sure
in that moment or in that one or two
hours everything
is is quiet like i'm in a vacuum do you
have a before you because also what you
do is so
actually dangerous like do you have
protocols before you say i'm not gonna
check my phone an hour before i'm not
gonna
no i don't go get that you're like i'm
tony hawk i don't need to do that
no it's not that i just i can check my
phone before i get on a skateboard
yeah i don't i never went that deep with
it i was never
like some great big methodical procedure
where it's like okay
this is what it has to happen before i
get out there and do this thing yeah
um and also just my
my um career skateboarding how it was
that it was
you wouldn't allow for that yeah right
right right right we would show but
you know in in the 80s we'd show up at a
skate shop and there's just a bunch of
shitty ramps in a parking lot and it was
like
go perform for the 200 kids that are
here
it's so cool they're not asking you like
do you need some water
and then so in order no one was asking
if we wanted a nice tea let's put it
that way
and you still have to bring it yourself
but so there's something i'm obsessed
with
with confidence versus like
no i'm confident only in the things i
know i'm competent in
you i'm saying that's like my i don't i
don't think i have confidence i just
have like oh i know i can do that
because i've just proved it to myself
and there's something so fascinating to
me about what we'd like any kind of
performance where it's like you have to
have confidence in order to
get good at it but you can't get
confidence unless you are good
it's like this thing of how do you build
that um
i yeah i agree i think i think through
the year especially when i was young
i just was so convinced that i could do
this stuff even against all odds in
terms of
my my body structure my skill level
at the time i i just was absolutely
convinced like i can
i can do that i know i can do that i
gotta figure it out and
and how old were you when you had that
like i know i can do that um
probably about 12 is when i started
to explore tricks that i knew hadn't
really been done before
and and i wanted to push that further
and i wanted to figure out how i could
fly like the older guys and
um and i started to kind of get ahead of
myself with
what i was doing and it was way outside
my skill level and then
i got a concussion i knocked my front
teeth out and everything was like
yeah you gotta you gotta take a little
slower and why
and do you after that um because then i
got my brain i think this is the
difference between the people that
that keep going and when and don't of
like well i just knocked my teeth out so
what's the worst thing that happened i
already knocked my teeth out this is the
perfect time to try that crazy thing
that's how my brain is i think i had i i
had a happy medium somewhere where it
was like yeah
yes i want to keep doing this i mean
that was there was a line of distinction
too is when
i woke up from the hospital and i knew
everything was uh was relatively okay my
first thought was
i'm not gonna quit skating and i think a
lot of people
that's the reason they quit interesting
i you know i tried to skate and then i
broke my wrist and i was like that's not
for me
and that for me it was like oh i learned
a lesson in that
i have to learn how to do rock and
roll's better that really was
like for me that was the takeaway is i
gotta learn how to clear my front trucks
when i do rock and rolls because if i
don't clear them
i get knocked unconscious and what's the
difference between somebody who takes
the broken wrist as a lesson and someone
who takes it as a stop sign
um well you know some they go pro
sometimes yeah
and that's something that just it could
be nature it could be nurture it could
be something
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
psychology of it is i think it's more
i didn't mind getting hurt for the sake
of progression never
in my life and and so i was willing to
take those hits i didn't
i didn't start skating because i thought
like i want to get crazy and i don't
care about my body it was more
along the along the way i thought oh i i
will get hurt
but i'm going to keep doing it and my
my parents were supportive but at some
point after
my second concussion and my second time
knocking down my teeth my mom was like
maybe you should take it you know
take a little easy and i was not hearing
any of that i think i also was lucky
in that when i was in that mode and when
i when i was
getting injured i was really young and
so it wasn't like i thought i was
choosing a career path
or it wasn't like i was struggling to
pay rent and i got to make this happen
because it hasn't really been this is
all i have no it was i was i wasn't even
high school yet so
uh for me it was just like this is the
most fun that i've ever had
and i'm learning stuff that i never
imagined i'd learn i've i've
met people that i think are fascinating
and creative and
and i identify with them because they're
misfits and they don't they don't belong
in team sports and so as all of a sudden
this whole new world was opened up to me
i was like this is my
place i love this and i'm going to chase
it as far as i can
i just got very lucky in that when i was
graduating high school
that's when i started to actually make
decent money
did you know you're answering the
question but like i was thinking about i
was like you were you kind of
built this thing that didn't exist like
you built off of other
you know of course or other people that
have done it before you but
is it weird to be like you didn't really
know what you were even building because
it had never been built
yeah i think that's well that's that's
part of the the fun too is that people
say
you know is this is this what you
dreamed and i was like i i didn't know
what i was dreaming that this didn't
exist
so it wasn't like there was someone to
set the standard that this is
you can become rich and famous and you
can have all the success and it was like
the the the most successful skateboarder
in that day got free gear and got their
picture in a magazine
and maybe they got flown to jacksonville
for a skate contest once a year
i mean that was that was the height of
success no one was killing it
everyone was just doing it because they
loved it and so
when i came up and had this unparalleled
success
it was it was all just shocking yeah and
it was all
it was a fun surprise it was incredible
but at the same time it was more
incidental to
wow people finally like what we do
totally or
they've always existed but now we have a
way to connect them all which is
i was thinking about um when your first
video game came out
was there a shock of like i didn't
realize this was so popular because it's
like you weren't
all over the world it was um yes it was
the
biggest uh like in your mind you're like
this is kind of just in america just in
san diego just
wherever i go and tour now it was more
of the global
i think i think what happened with the
video game is that i
worked hard on on developing the game
with with obviously
neversoft and activision because i
wanted to represent skateboarding
authentically that was that was my whole
that was my goal of the game
and in my eyes the the
most success we will enjoy with this
game is that we got skaters
to buy playstations because they think
the game is cool
for me that was that was it wow that was
that was the height of success
and what i didn't consider or or
imagine is that it was a really fun game
to play regardless if you skated or not
and so many video gamers got into it and
people were drawn to skateboarding
because they enjoyed playing the game
and they got out there and they're like
this hurts way more out right
but they did enjoy it enough that it it
got skating they had it it
enjoyed this giant boom there was a
study that came out that said that kids
that play video games actually have
faster fighting reflexes
than kids that don't play video games
which is kind of like it makes sense
when you think about it but do you ever
like
visualize it happen in your head because
when i think about kids playing you know
video games with skateboarding you're
also accidentally visualizing yourself
what do you mean did i did i play the
game and then
did you before you oh before the game
existed did you visualize yourself
doing the trick and then yes do it yes
absolutely i mean that was the only way
i could do new tricks is that i
saw myself completing it and doing it
because
you can't with skating you can't just
try it on a whim you can't just
throw caution to the wind and say hope
this works
might not because it's not going to work
accidentally
you have to already have visualize
yourself doing it
and then it's like you've you finally
have brought it to fruition
and you saw it through i find this with
comedy a little bit it's it's it's way
less
you know punk rock but you know i always
get clowned on when i'm the one with the
notebook and i'm the one like
recording myself and then changing the
word and everything and i'm like i'm not
pretending this is easy for me
like this is really hard for me to do it
takes a really long time for me to make
this look easy you're seeing how the
sausage is made if you think i'm a dork
like fine
but is there a culture and we also are
kind of in the culture anyway of like
the the kid that flunks at school is the
coolest and the straight a student is
the nerd you know i feel like it might
be changing a little bit that now the
trihards are cool and not nerds or you
know
as much anymore but did you ever feel
like your sort of methodical strategic
approach was like just like different or
not
um well what i've learned through
all the ups and downs of skating and all
the all the
diversity now that we have is everyone
has their own process
and and yes you can you can zero in on
people and say oh that
that person has got it that person is
going to go can take it a lot further
even if they don't don't do it the way i
do it even if they don't yeah but i can
see
i mean lizzie armando is a perfect
example i i see i have seen her
i've seen her try a trick for so
much longer than anyone else that i have
ever known
hours wow um i like one example is we
were shooting we were shooting our
birdhouse uh our that's our company we
were shooting our video called saturdays
that we released three years ago but
we were in seattle we're at the skate
park there was a trick she was trying
she started trying this trick and
i was with her for at least an hour and
a half
and it that was it this was the whole
thing and an hour and a half especially
for me that's it
that's my whole day and are you talking
to her during this are you just laughing
i'm giving her i'm trying to give her
advice but at some point
it was more that she just had to commit
to the landing she had the
she had the the uh line for it she had
the right motion and it was just
after a while it was like all right you
just gotta you gotta commit you gotta
stand like you just gotta do it commit
as in like
like there was a there was no physical
issues it was just the mental thing of
you have to phys
you have to mentally commit commit yeah
but also just
to like to really commit herself to
stand up and uh on that
landing because it was like all the
pieces were there stick it she she had
the jerk she had
it was it was kind of this gap so she
had the trajectory to go over the gap
and then she needed to put her board on
the wall and when she put her board on
the wall you could just tell her legs
would collapse
like i'm not going to do it and when i
see people do that
i know that usually i assume they're
just they're not going to get it
because everything's there for the
taking and they won't they won't take it
and so my friend and i went and
left and ate and
came back and she was still
in the mix still trying it just as hard
same thing over and over and over and
there at some point i'm thinking like
it's not i don't think it's gonna happen
and then she just made it
wow and i've never seen anyone
persevere in that way that whatever her
thought process was
was just like i had to go through four
and a half hours of this trick
to make it and then in your estimation
what was the psychological block
if you could have just gone and it would
have been like you can't answer that's
what i'm saying
her process is so much different um and
i saw her do the same thing with
learning how to do the full loop ramp
where
her her first attempts were ones that
when i have seen other people try it and
and fail the way she did i discourage
them from doing it all together
because i just said you don't have the
technique yeah and she just kept going
and figured it out
um i'm just i'm just using exactly i
just love that that's not my process
that's never been how i could do it
um so it's fascinating to see the
differences but
but i do see it and i mean we um we're
sponsoring uh this girl jesse she's
eight
and i can see with her you know i i
watch her skate and
i'm like she she's relentless and that's
so fascinating to me because sometimes i
need that
like so i need to and the word bully is
so like polarizing these days but i need
to taunt myself sometimes like
like if i don't do a joke the way that i
am capable of or whatever
and then i feel like shit for two days
because you can't really correct it
until you've
you can't feel good about yourself again
and in my case unless you get up on
stage and kill again
so you just feel like shit until you get
on stage again in fact i'll tell you my
my thought process
it's very similar to that is that when
i'm trying something over and over and i
just get it stuck in a rut
and i'm falling and then i'm doing what
i call the walk of shame where i'm i
fall and then i walk around the ramp and
i climb stairs and i'm just like all
right
go again and then at some point i'm like
i am not climbing these fucking stairs
again yep
that's it yeah and then it's like my
motivation is to not climb the stairs
again it has nothing to do with
skateboarding at this point no i fuck
these fucking stairs
yeah i'm not i don't want to climb the
stairs again and then i make it
yeah this is so this is only like i want
to stop
having to do like the now part of me too
is like i'm tired of wasting my
friend's time from him filming it our
codependents can sometimes
get us to do something way faster yeah
exactly i now abruptly interrupt the
great tony hawk
to talk about a different kind of
shredding shaving without it
no shredding here is what we're trying
to talking about shredding
the whole point is that benton and emily
made us a little
dating game to talk to us and explain
how shaving with billy is a goddamn
miracle
it's so that you can fall in love with
the perfect razor
hint yeah billy i mean you already have
a lover we just thought he might want
you to shave
contestant number one the billy razor
what do you
think is more important in a
relationship being reliable or being
fun i think being honest is really
important for example
no pink tax billy offers the most
comfortable
shave and trust me i'll prove it to you
but i also think it's important to be
fun which is why i also arrive in
beautiful
colorful packaging and i'll show up
right at your door ready to service you
contestant number two drugstore razor
same question
well i think it's important to be cheap
easy to access and only cut you on
occasions mainly just your toes
i've never been cut on any occasion for
my billy razor so
if you each could do just one thing to
show that you care about me
what would it be billy razor vs
drugstore razor
i would run along every curve of your
body treating you with respect
making sure we got super close and never
hurt you
oh i also love that you thought that was
awkward because it was
gonna be so sexy that it was gonna make
me uncomfortable you deserve to feel
your best
and i just wanna be sure to help you
comfortably be in control of that
um drugstore razor i mean
yeah i'd take you home and give you a
few good swipes before i
totally fuck your shit up hell yeah
hey what sets you apart from the others
billy razor i'm chic and hard working
i come in a bag for about three bucks
who are you gonna pick
oh
this is tough billy you're the winner
i'll hail and to express a little love
for our show
go to mybilly.com whitney it's a small
way you can support us
while you are getting the support you
need
in a razor this is just nine dollars to
get your starter kit plus free shipping
as always go to mybilly.com
whitney spelled my b i l l
i e dot com slash whitney
all right now um we are gonna do one of
my favorite things
uh i'm gonna take a quiz we want you to
know
how serious student loans are student
loans are serious and it's a big deal
that we have earnest as a sponsor
so we want to test if you really know
how serious this is i
respond that i do think it's serious it
does say response
yeah good job um they don't know what
you're talking about
you guys are writing my lines now and
sometimes they write it
so uh so clear
so clear that if i get one word wrong
they get upset but says in parentheses
whitney responds
and you did a good job thank you i
micromanage you okay
got it got it first question whitney in
2019 how much was the average student
loan debt for a bachelor's degree
eighty thousand dollars okay this is the
average but um
sure uh isn't it crazy twenty eight
thousand nine hundred and fifty dollars
well that's what state schools oh with
state schools
yeah that's if you average everyone's
total together and divide them by the
amount of schools
like well state schools is less than
private schools private schools is
probably like
okay why explain the answer what's that
question did you learn how to compute
averages in
college college i was going to say not
yet another reason i don't owe my
college
any money because i don't know the
answer to that question emily got your
next question emily
in 2020 the u.s student loan debt
reached
what it's peak
that's true i mean you're not wrong one
point seven
trillion dollars in student loans in the
usa uh-huh
brilliant and the last question
how much student loan debt do you think
is in this room oh wow
to be fair whenever wrote the questions
it was just the two of us so i would
just say
and i don't have any um
okay just between youtube
for 30 thousand dollars
sixty thousand dollars one million
one billion dollars here's here's the
deal y'all need to go to some kind of
educational program
uh or else you're gonna end up doing
what we do for
a living so uh make sure to go to school
but then
uh bring ernest on retainer
because ernest is offering our listeners
a 100 cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a 100
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com whitney terms and conditions
apply
once again you get a 100
cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com whitney
to refinance your student loans no just
your
not available and conditions
not available in all states why visit
earnest.com
whitney for more details terms and
conditions apply earnest student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls number 120 4917
comma california financing law number
605-4788 going to give you a second to
jot that down
303 2nd street suite 401
n san francisco ca 94107
visit earnest.com licenses for a full
list of licenses
i'm happy to read you those licenses
verbatim add that to her wikipedia page
she did go to college i'm obsessed with
like the how
when you're great at one thing you're
weirdly qualified at some other thing
that you may not
even know you're qualified at like for
example i believe stand-ups are
i can always tell you like how much time
has passed
for some whatever reason like if i'm on
a plane i can be like it's been two
hours and 17 minutes
oh right just because we're on stage i'm
good at measuring distances because of
that that's fascinating um because i
know how
wide ramps are and everything that when
you build ramps everything is
four foot by eight foot sections
so i can tell you like this room is
about 16 feet wide or 12. yeah you would
like cut it in half or
double it like based on the increments
that you do know about
that's so fascinating to me um and then
uh
and then i want to talk about just like
fear for a second because
when i watch you i'm like this guy i was
like is it just because there weren't
like pages and pages and pages on
youtube of like nasty falls like
that like what like i'm obsessed with
like cave diving like i can't understand
how why anyone would feel the need to do
it would want to do it and i look at
what you do and i'm like i'm so glad
that i never tried i need because i can
actually enjoy it i think as soon as
like
doing stand up means i don't get to
enjoy comedy i don't get to enjoy comedy
movies that might like
a lot a lot's taken from you as an
entertainer
consumer if you become an entertainer
just because you can never fully
like surrender you know and um but
do you ever feel and then i did hear you
saying you felt scared sometimes like
you know because a lot of these people a
lot of people like you do have like an
amygdala thing or like uh
you know something where you're like oh
you're just built and you have like a
gift that
yeah but i never i never approached
something just like let's do it
let's you know i don't care like just
you know death or glory it was more that
i
i have all the pieces to this thing and
if i can put them all together
and and the timing is right i could
probably make it happen and that that's
always been my approach based on physics
and facts so i don't have to bring
fear into it because it's all just yeah
it's all just data yeah and experience
yeah so
i guess it's a little more methodical
than than you might think
um there are other friends of mine that
they do just go for it
and sometimes they pay the price but
sometimes they make it and it looks like
they're
you know they're riding a bucking bronco
but they make it and it's awesome
that was yeah that could never be
duplicated that was totally do you ever
like
know if something was like like you said
you got lucky on that gap thing
like did you or are you just like
on the gap on the gap the first time you
did the trick for the galaxy shoot
um is there such a thing as luck
yeah well i think that i
not that i got lucky i think it was it
was that
i was so i mean maybe there was a little
bit of luck
everything came together all at once and
and
my my headspace was
this is it you're doing this right now
yeah this is like nothing else matters
this is the thing you do it
everything you know this is what's gonna
happen when i did it i thought
i was done and i was not prepared at all
mentally for
do that again if i had known we were
gonna shoot that a couple times
or that there was a test run of it i
would have a totally different approach
see but that's fascinating would you
have held back on the first one
probably yeah yeah so then get their
camera
right yeah well that that's the thing is
it entertaining you're learning the hard
way
oh but i'll tell you so and i didn't
really have the clout to
say that back then you know like i said
i just thought i was i was lucky to be
there
i i was but you were also what they
needed you more than you you know
yeah but there were other skaters so
they they had their
fill the gaps but um it's funny to say
that because
fast forward to i just did a commercial
a couple weeks ago i don't think i can
say what it's for but
uh they wanted a couple of pretty
spectacular tricks
on their script and their their
storyboards
and i told them ahead of time i said
look you guys
if if i do that you get it one's all you
get
yeah that's it i you know i this this is
not something that i can just churn out
and there were a couple times where
there was one time especially where i
i did this thing and i was surprised
that i did actually because it just
wasn't the terrain for that kind of
trick
and they as soon as i did it they're
like yeah can we get it from uh
i see you guys you guys can get it again
you don't you don't have it
i'm sorry that's it so this is like
making
my heart take a shit in my chest it's
making me it's i'm like shaking i'm so
angry because
like it took me a long time to learn
that in stand up the first time you're
shooting your special
the first take is just a camera
rehearsal there's none of it's usable
like don't
like i now always add a day so if you
have one night to shoot your special you
have a
seven o'clock show and a nine o'clock
show thursday night you get in there and
you just do a rehearsal for the camera
guys it's not fair to them to not
you know what i mean they have to yeah
are there any like and because you know
some of the best camera
dps in the world shoot golf because it's
so hard to
follow it you know what i mean like are
there any people that like if you go on
a second you go i want this dp oh
absolutely yeah for sure yeah i have a
couple of key
filmers that's so funny can you just do
that again from a different angle like
what
yeah and it was funny because this at
this particular shoot
we didn't have uh a skater filmer
on board because uh the one that i
usually use
was busy that day he was traveling
already so um
i had to rely on more
uh traditional dps yeah
and you know one of our guys from i do
have a production company
they they allowed him to help set up one
shot so on this particular trick
he got the shot and it was it was good
enough
so yeah you guys can just pay us a
million dollars right
yeah exactly but but there are there's
there's a couple guys that skate um
my friend chris gregson is one of them
who he is one of the best skaters
already
and so he's this unicorn because he can
follow you through any terrain
or any over any gap and so you'll see
some
footage of someone skating and then
they'll jump some crazy thing and the
camera goes along with them and you're
like how
what how did that happen see i think
that is such an incredible point and
worth bringing up because
like you know uh vocations like yours
there's also
a ton of other jobs supporting the
vocation that having experienced
doing the the skill makes so the um
person that shot the free solo
documentary
um what's the guy's name can you just
tell me his name so i don't know jimmy
chin
exactly so he he's also a climber and
and no one could have
made that movie had jimmy chin not been
able to follow this you know this guy
around
yeah absolutely you know so it's like an
order to have like there's a specialized
sort of fleet of dps that can also skate
which that just like makes me so happy
yeah and well like i said my friend
chris he
he has gone on to do all kinds of things
and now he's getting hired by
other studios to get different angles of
things because suddenly they realize
that he can get up in there and
remain on a skateboard and get in the
air and um it's pretty cool i actually
got to do that
uh a long time ago i i was tony the
tiger for a frost flakes commercial
in like 89 88
so if you look up a frostbite commercial
hold on and he's skating
it's hard to find i don't think i went
down a rabbit hole trying to find it
once
okay don't we we'll find it but um but i
had to wear this
skin tight suit i mean this is like way
before cgi or anything and
and or like professional cgi
it's a bittersweet call isn't it what's
that we want you to skate in this
commercial
in a tiger costume yeah well that's that
was a funny thing especially in the late
80s i got a few
calls to do commercials but it was
always like you're too old
to be a principal because i was 20
something
that's right and in there you know the
stereotypical skater was
12. oh wow and so obviously a lot has
changed since then but i was just
telling you that because at the frost
face commercial i ended up doing
camera work uh for my friend who was the
principal
fascinating and then how there was a
time where you things got
you know a little like quiet and skating
in general and you were video editing uh
i was yeah because uh
i had bought a video editing system i
actually borrowed money from my parents
um because i was starting to get into it
and i and we had a few
different skate videos that that came
out at that time
so i was able to basically my sponsor
pal pearl to bones brigade allowed me to
do my own section
with my friends and then just hand them
the finished product
um i mean it wasn't spectacular but it
was it was fun
and because i had that and my income was
dropping so dramatically
i started freelancing as a video editor
and i got a couple of jobs that i was
able to
make the rent from but it was it was
slim pickings
i'm so into this i'm so into though what
do with uh if you do a certain job doing
something else how it makes you better
at the thing you
already were well i think i'm very
thankful for those years because
i learned a lot about video editing and
i like you know my i wasn't great at it
but i learned
to get better at it and then when the
tools came in
to play that we have now i mean your
phone is a whole
video editing suite and now i can do my
own
content right and i understand how to
time edits and how to sync music and
then all that kind of
sitting around waiting for someone else
to do it and not get the timing right
because that's not the trick
right you should look that's not the
same that was i was all self-taught in
those years
and i'm just thankful that i went
through that and and yeah it felt like
it felt impossible at the time it was
just like what am i doing
i do remember there was a moment where
so you guys i don't know you guys aren't
that old but you'll appreciate that i
i bought my editing system from a
consignment place in burbank because
it was so old and shitty that no one's
buying it and it's all
it's all i could afford with what my
parents would let me borrow
was a three-quarter editing system
so three-quarter tapes were like whoa
giant
yeah tapes you know and so i'd have to i
have to record all of our high eight
footage onto that
i'm going but but it's that is the type
of shit though i think that takes people
mentally the next level
i'm so obsessed with editing because it
taught me you know uh
how to sort of like you know be better
conversations because i'm able to go oh
like you can edit that out
and like oh you know what i can pause
here and we can always cut that if we
need so when you're working or
performing you can actually be better
when you're on camera because you're
like oh i know
yeah it's fixable later editing for
social media
purposes where it's like i know that
this has got to move a little bit
quicker
pull these pauses out and also like for
instagram make it a minute long
100 and would you say to the next
generation of skaters which i know
everyone always like what would you say
to them like
is it like learn how to fucking edit i
would say no i'd make your content
yes and no i mean definitely the
influencers have their whole crew around
them but
uh i would say that i always tell them
learn everything about your craft if
it's skating
learn the business of it learn what it
you know what does it take to do ads
and yeah same thing like social media
editing and stuff because just being a
good skater
is not going to necessarily take you as
far as you
hope you could be the best skater and
not have all these other elements and
not have a career that you imagine
and be the business person like i mean
that's been i think and so
i i when i started
a business i embraced learning all the
boring stuff
and that benefited me greatly through
the years be to me that's when i was
like what do i have to go to school what
do i go to college and i don't remember
anything i'm like i think i
i believe what the way the the college
and high school like pay off is that you
have to
practice sitting through something you
think is boring because that's just such
a big part of being successful you just
have to sit still when you're fucking
bored that's a lot of being successful
even at your dream
yeah well i took i took computers i mean
this is you know i was it was like 84 85
but i took computer
class and that was super helpful to me
later on i can't believe you saw that
because i was the
dork who had to be there was you had a
choice in our high school between speech
and drama which was just like silly
running around
and computer and like keeping checks or
like how to and
they put a box over our hands and yeah
and they put a box over our hands and we
had to type and not look down
and i hated it and now i'm like i can
type one i'm talking
like it's just so interesting like as a
young person when to capitulate
to something even though it's and then
and then when to be punk rock and go
this is stupid
and then we'd have to write fake checks
and like balance our checkbooks and shit
like it was so
it was like wife class or something shit
that's what i always thought of home
i mean you know i i wasn't like
it wasn't that i was some great uh
advocate for
equal rights back then when i was 15 but
it did feel like home
that seems like such a like such a
home economics yeah well yeah like a
wife homemaker
but just the idea that a woman has to
know home economics but she's not
allowed to earn any money it's like
can i earn some money yeah it was
straight up it was straight up like
jetsons
know about economics um okay so now we
are going to come to the part of the
interview where someone that actually
deserves to interview you is going to
ask you some questions and i'm gonna
come sit next to you over there okay
cool
just so kevin christie is my best friend
comes with me on the road
uh has a show on youtube about
skateboard stickers
and is gonna show you a couple awesome
because i basically was like kevin tell
me some questions i can ask i was like i
can't even ask this without it being so
obvious that it's not my
future like he he's i'll send you the
questions he
sent me that i was gonna try to ask you
with a straight face
and pretend they were mine oh man i
would love that yeah it was i think
do you remember the chris farley show
yeah this is gonna be a little like that
okay okay cool and i'll see i hope i
hope i can do it justice because
and i'm gonna interrupt i'm not the best
historian or collector
of skates i won't i'm i just love the
way they look
oh i did want to ask you yeah does it
hurt that none of your sons have a mixed
weave
um actually my son keegan is he's got it
pretty well
he's got a hot mixed web he does yeah um
yeah i will i'll show you a photo he's
my doppelganger for sure
that's exciting and i do right before
kevin you start i just
what i'm sure everyone asks you this but
what is going on with you and your son
being such a good was there ever any
trepidation of like i don't want him to
fucking do this
or are you like i want him to have oh to
be a pro yeah
no actually when he was um
around 14 or 15 he started to shy away
from skating
uh because he felt that pressure you
felt that
that thing where people were just like
oh you're tony's son
there's a big expectation and he started
he started leaning into motocross
and we didn't really have the reese him
and
his mom and i didn't have the resources
or the time to
to facilitate that because that's like a
whole life it's a whole thing
yeah it's like a gymnastics kid yeah
it's like you're you're driving out to
the cross with the track which is two
hours from us
and you're there all day and you gotta
get the equipment you gotta
you gotta keep things in check and and
he was doing it but it was just it was
just so scattered and then one day we
were driving home from the track and i
said
and he was talking about how he wanted
to try to get sponsored
and i i said you know i you know riley i
think you're you know you're doing
pretty good
i'm motocross but you're you're really
good at skating
and if you were ever to get sponsored
and it pains me to say that no
he's a fucking alien on a board like
he's really i mean he would he was
from a young age um and he obviously was
surrounded by it but he took to it and
so
he did take that to heart and and i
think in that moment decided i'm going
to forge my own way
so it was like i can be talking i'm not
going to be sponsored by all your
companies i'm gonna find my own sponsors
and and then he
he had a crew in oceanside uh where
they all skated they're all the same age
they started making their videos they
called themselves the shep dogs and they
became their own thing
and then that's when he realized that he
could do it his own way i want to do it
but on my terms like is that such a
primal thing for a son and a father
like the moment when it's like you're my
hero but i also need to be my own
man and and i mean i'm fascinated with
watching him because he does
he definitely had he has carved a unique
style even in the street world
and he is so good at like there's tricks
that's just like how
how is that easy for you it's fucking i
don't understand he's so proud
how's his coffee shop doing oh yeah it's
good they're killing it now but let me
so when you see him do a trick
that looks so are you like i could have
done that when i was your age or you're
just like
no no because the style of skating the
things you focused on just they weren't
like that and we didn't know that was
possible i think a lot of it has to do
with
if if you know something is possible and
has been done it's
it's easier to attain than uh i don't
even know if it's going to work
and that is that's more daunting and
more challenging
so now it's like i know all these things
exist and people have done it and
survived like that
they talk about like pat duffy was the
first one to do like a grind down a
round
rail and everyone was like well we saw
pat do it but who the fuck did pat see
like tyler's just nuts he was just
double kink like in the rain yeah in the
rain
no he's parts in the rain that's true
it's in the rain you're just like what
the
like everyone was like what the hell was
that dude yeah and then it changed all
kinds of yeah and it just changed yeah
and and well for instance i you know i
started skating i was 10 years old
kickflips weren't invented until i was
15 or 16.
nowadays it's like here's a skateboard
do a kickflip yeah month one
yeah you know that i have a um i believe
that you are
the only feminist cat caller because
you can drive by women and go do a kid
live that's like positive cat calling
that's like
super feminist cat calling um okay so
kevin take
us on this question i will figure out a
way to make them my idea after he says
them but these are ones
i never could have pulled off okay uh my
first question is do you remember
i me remember you um when i was 11 i met
you at valsurf
i waited four hours to get your
autograph uh you gave me your autograph
on my shirt
uh you skated a long trip you know what
it was because that beard threw me off
okay so if i shaved you would definitely
absolutely 100 lose the glasses you
weren't wearing glasses then
no i didn't need them remembers
remembers me
[Laughter]
um you now skate for vans an independent
and you live in san diego are you going
to start a rockabilly band
[Laughter]
uh i i can only hope
i'm waiting i'm waiting for that wanted
ad right right
um what do you miss more lappers copers
nose rails um
nose rails really yeah cause i i do
when i do backstairs i grab the nose and
that would just give me a little more
leverage what the hell was a lapper for
like
oh lapra was so you don't hang up on the
on coping
on coping yeah okay yeah okay it was
like a safety device i never skated like
a full-size half-pipe i didn't have
access
well it was also it would help it would
help with like going up curbs yeah
or you know this yeah had a lot of
purposes okay
great nose rail what
most underrated skater of your era you
think
um man that is really
hard well i mean what is my era
80s i have 80s vert 80s vert the contest
is
wow why you gotta throw that one at me
uh
i'm sorry we can come back to it
i have to think about it do you accept
my apologies the next question
are you are you still mad at me um i
think uh
well there was a skating aaron dieter
and
he is credited for doing the first ollie
blunt i think
really yeah wow or uh or todd congeller
that's my answer todd congelier
todd conjure you kind of look like todd
conchaler which is kind of weird
always have because maybe that's why his
name came to mind but he did he did some
lip tricks that
that we're still hoping to do wow
wow in fact i learned something recently
and someone was like consciously
fascinating because there's there's a
market difference like you know when you
ask a comedian who their favorite
comedian is most people have never heard
of them
you know right which is kind of i'm
always fascinated by that
trick you can do that riley can't that
you kind of lured over him
and vice versa does he taunt you one
time i beat him in a game of skate
doing a inver an invert varial
because we the game of skate was in our
backyard park yeah
so i did an invert varial and he was
like come on yeah cheating kind of
how did you ground him is there any
version of your grab and you can't skate
for two weeks
you can't do that you never really need
to be grounded um
i yeah i can't think of
some no in your opinion if a parent has
a kid who's skating
should you say you can't skate for like
should that be a punishment or is that
just of
it could be but you know they're gonna
sneak out and go skate right
and the more you tell someone not to do
something the more they can do it right
okay
um are you sick of bird imagery in your
graphics
you didn't do it again way to go he's
talking to you derrick
yeah it's just sort of like our
production birdhouse
i mean yeah they sell they do sell they
do it is hard to find a unique
concept in that sense yes uh looking
back on your 80s fashion
perhaps too much that's not too much
pastel or are you like
should have gone harder well considering
that
dayglow neon is in right i was ahead of
the curve
yeah started that shit that's why i had
a pink helmet
there you go see yeah but you wouldn't
wear it now i think i think it's
something
to wear at some point no at some point i
i felt that
so much it was like dude that i just
went all black so when you see me in the
last
15 years all my gear is black that's it
it's just like i did my time i did my
time and i'm just gonna let the skating
do the talk and i can't be a cartoon of
myself
if i show up in colors yeah now i'm
impressed when you look back on their
looks who do you think regrets their
looks more
staub or hasoy there's no regrets for
any of those guys
they feel it they feel it well kevin's
still running it that's true
um and christian would probably if you
have
if you could have the hair you used to
right right
um favorite all-time skater
um rodney mullen is the godfather of
modern skateboarding
yeah without question he's the reason
that
people are the kids go out and try half
the tricks they do for sure can i ask a
crazy question just as
um i try to just be like what's the
audience thinking um
uh that's just my excuse for how i
interject into conversations um
um is that how much of skating is about
making it
look easy and elegant and how much of
you know does that make sense like the
style
it does uh and i can answer you in in
the way that when i was young all i
cared about was were tricks
and i did not care how they looked and i
got a lot of flack for it
because in in those years especially
with christian asoy christian soy was
the king of style
and he was my main competitor and and
they called me either a circus
skater or a robot oh wow um so it counts
for a lot
mm-hmm and how you do something is
you're saying clearly you are neither
there
what's that you're not you're neither
right just to clear those questions
not a robot but that's fascinating
because i think it's it's in
stand up in a lot of art forms like i'm
not trying to pretend this is like this
is hard i'm trying
sam kinnison some of my favorite uh you
know comedians were sweating on stage
and it's like physically
but you you there's pressure to make
things look pretty i think i think i
yeah there is and also i just came into
my own style later on
where i figured out how to maneuver
things where i'm doing these hard tricks
but it doesn't look
so outlandish or robotic and so you just
kind of
you know just with practice and and with
with honing your
your uh how you do things in a way that
you want them to look
but there's also it's in in stand-up
it's kind of the opposite it's like you
made that look really nice but that's
not good
that was all performance and no skill
there's no joke there yeah there's no
joke there that was all style and no
substance you know so we have sort of a
like oh yeah what do you do without the
guitar bitch what do you do without the
fucking you know what i mean that suit
let's see who you are without the piano
you know like it's make it dirtier and
dirtier it's sort of
what we do did you ever think like
christian's trick looked better because
of that weave
always because he had that weave too it
wasn't even just any
like if christian learned a trick that's
how you want to do that trick yeah
you know when he learned when he learned
twist it was like oh of course
his are the best yeah who's is his style
the style you would have like maybe
wanted to emulate the most
um in in some ways but i i was thankful
that i
had my wiry skeleton
body that i could do other moves and
other spins
yeah that maybe he wasn't able to or
didn't want to your burial game was way
stronger
yeah yes but also just learning to to
spin you know that it's because of my
body type
and how robotic i was i was able to
figure out how to spin
more and i'm really thankful for that um
but yeah you know christian was it was
like
skating against johnny depp just came in
and like
he looked really cool he looked really
cool yeah
um birdhouse alum you're the proudest
stuff
um wow
bird house alum companies called
merchants
and he's saying like what who are you um
i was subtitling it
could you put on some pretty heavy dudes
yeah i i would have to say heath
yeah um because i i put heath on when he
was a
scrappy little amateur
tiny skater wearing huge jeans and extra
large shirts
right and um he went on to
he went on to do way more than i ever
imagined yeah
and what did you see in him um i saw
that that fire and that desire to and he
was trying
huge stuff when he was tiny oh wow um i
mean his
his you know we used to make sponsor
videos his sponsor me video half of that
video is what i put into his first video
part for birdhouse
oh that's crazy yeah um i've noticed in
the last like maybe
10 years your kind of perception from
the skate public has changed
like the kind of tony hawk's the
corporate dude
it seems like that's like gone away like
that's not how people like it's
the respect to me level has gone up or
like no no this guy
matters and he held it together kind of
when it was falling apart
i guess i i you know it wasn't by design
it was just more that
i just always loved skating and i think
that that started to shine through
because whatever it was the the
corporate
um opportunities and things that i had
we're starting to fade especially
in the last five or six years and i
never faltered like i just kept skating
because that's what i love doing and
it has allowed me to have this
fantastical life
and i have my own private ramp and i'm
able to
shoot video and do things like that's
all i want when the only thing negative
someone can say about you is like
they made a lot of money in business
you're like well if that's the worst
thing you got
yeah well but it was also i was i was
the one who was
marked as the sellout because i had some
of the first
big corporate sponsorships especially in
the early 2000s
and somehow that was but how is it
selling like
i'd like to get into that yeah i think
well with the idea
in in their head and what i've come to
understand through all this is that
they think that you're you're changing
your values
right to make money from these bigger
companies
and it was like dude i ate mcdonald's my
whole life
yeah yeah yeah when they asked to pay me
hell yes you know how much money they
owe me yeah then we're going to break
even and i'm able to
i'm able to to bring in a new audience
to skateboarding through their
advertising dollars like that's amazing
to me
yeah and i know i always like what do
you think i'm going to start like
skating the balls like i'm only gonna
you're still gonna do what you're right
and but but endemic sponsors especially
in those days they didn't have
that kind of marketing money and they
didn't you know i i absolutely
i kept i kept my core sponsors obviously
it wasn't like
i'm only exclusive to whatever nike
reebok or something it wasn't like that
it was just more that
that well now we have these bigger
options and and we can
we can take skateboarding to a whole new
audience yeah and i think that there's
that you know there's a lot of this in
comedy where it's like if someone gets
too successful we're like
like you know it is how we just feel
better about the fact that we don't have
that thing that's all it's how we
self-suit that's all but i think that
like you're saying through through the
most recent times in the last
10 15 years obviously many other skaters
have had those opportunities and that's
okay now
yeah but it's going to be different now
i was definitely the one
that was the one that they had to target
was yeah you had to take the bullshit
dude
yeah yeah and and i think that my
getting so much ridicule from my style
as a kid prepared me for all of that
right right i think that's that is such
an important
like point and when you know i know a
lot of you know girls are going to
listen this and be like i want to be a
skater and i want to be skater and like
whitney why don't you ask him about like
if it's rough being a female skater with
like dudes only and what that's like and
i always say that when whenever someone
comes up to me they're like it's toxic
in the hallway the comedy story like the
guys are bullies i'm like dude i
i know that what's happening isn't ideal
but they are
making you stronger i know that sounds
if it's illegal or that's not what i'm
talking about it is weird because
i mean i grew up in the 70s like bullies
we didn't no one said
you're a bully you just get picked on we
called them teachers i got
picked on all the time yeah and i got
picked on because i was a skater and
then i'm skating
and then older skaters are picking on me
because of my skate style and
and i'm not saying that that's necessary
but it readied me for everything to come
yeah so it's like there is this like
like and this is
you know it's tricky now because
everyone's so like you know
trying to treat everyone with like kid
gloves when i'm like just get picked on
just learn how to tolerate it and you'll
just get stronger i wouldn't encourage
it but it does happen and i think at
some point you just say fuck it i gotta
believe myself and
but i just mean go make this happen by
the time you're going to do tony hawk's
like huge
tour and you're like the headlining act
like if someone goes you suck you're not
even gonna fucking hear it because
you're so used to it yeah
you know it's like that that this is a
horrendous sort of story but i i
see the the the sort of intention behind
it where um
uh serena williams's dad used to go hire
people to yell at them when they were
practicing tennis
he told the story on the howard stern
show i don't know why
i mean it's hardcore that's the next
level it's like next level but it's like
if i had a daughter who was skating i
would be like can you guys just beat up
on her just a little so that she's like
prepare i don't mean like hit her i just
beat up on you
huh skating beats up on you plenty just
give her a hard time like don't give
special treatment to someone that needs
to be
tough you know what i mean don't like
cuddle someone this i don't believe you
would do that i don't
i i will do what i will choke my
daughter out if i have whatever prepares
her for hollywood
we now take another break sorry i i want
to take a break but i'm just distracted
by emily's uh
attire for the night i'm dressed as
fancy this is me fancy
okay why but why are you dressed like
this
because we owe brook linen a fancy spot
that we take seriously and we're demure
and beautiful
because the last one we did is this is
your definition of do me shady
no i'm dressed up this is you do me a
show of respect i'm
dressed you look like jean by name
ramsay
thank you if we knew where she was
oh wait now or then
let me just show you why we have to do
the brooklyn and ad
in a much fancier way right now okay
because i feel like we nailed it last
time yeah i was there i think it was
good
i loved it holy shit we
can't find the brooklyn in sheetz sheet
man eat sheet and die i would gladly eat
sheet and die
if it was brooklyn and she she really
hit the fan
she just hit the fan we can't find the
brooklyn and she
sheets quick without a paddle we are up
sheets creek
i'm just repeating all of emily's jokes
by the way
in a much less funny pantaminer holy
sheet
when is benting gonna come back benton
sheep for brains
benjen don't be such a sheep for brains
this is a sheety outfit
this is a sheet show this is a total
sheet show
god i feel like sheen which is a
compliment if it's a brooklyn and she
because i she i eat she didn't die ben
uh well this ad really went to sheets oh
my god
tomorrow i'm gonna feel like absolute
cheat if it's a brooklyn
sheet i'm gonna feel great and super
smooth well benton we're doing a bit
where benton
appears as a ghost and art has started
to imitate life
should we just do this without him i'm
scared sheetless
this is a shitty it's a very sheety
ad read holy shit this hat is long
i just want everyone watching and
listening to know that this will
no way be worth the wait okay here we go
the moment we've all been waiting for
the eyes are so far away the fact that
we spent time
planning this bit out the difference
between your eyes was that why
i see things those are for you i see
things you can't see because i'm from
the other side
okay you cut your eyes after you put it
on no before which is the problem
okay but that's how wide you thought
your eyes were which i'm dead move on
i have no notes yeah what was wrong i
have no
problems i do think this is easily the
best ad we've ever done
but you want to talk some sheets
i'm going to talk to you about that
damn it's summer again and that means
hot sunny days
and nights are too hot to get any sleep
enter brooklyn in
crisp sheets that breathe to keep you
cool mean you can say goodbye to sweaty
summer nights
brooklyn it has something for every
product need ideal for a seasonal
refresh because they're launching new
products colors and patterns all the
time
i'm talking buttery soft and breathable
sheets plus absorbing towels and
shh cozy robes and comfy loungewear
you'll want to never take off they're so
confident no cool products they come
with a 365 day warranty
they've received over 75 000 five-star
reviews and counting
thanks brooke lennon sorry we keep
fucking these up
you know what it is we're getting too
much sleep
if there's anything we prioritize at
this podcast i think you probably
noticed it's physical comfort as you can
tell by emily's outfit
so give yourself the comfort refresh you
deserve and get it for less
at brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com and
use the promo code whitney make sure
you're modeling emily
promo code whitney to get twenty dollars
off with a minimum purchase of one
hundred dollars
that's b r o o k l i n
e n dot com and enter promo code
whitney for twenty dollars off with a
minimum purchase of a hundred dollars
that's brook linen b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n
promo code whitney this podcast is
brought to you by hydro
my favorite favorite favorite way to
work out
i did not work out at all for i want to
say like a year and a half
until this item device
entered the mark came on the scene and
now it's all i do i'm taking a little
break because of my severed thumb
but it is a state-of-the-art rowing
machine just
i can actually do it with my separate
a state-of-the-art rowing machine
designed to transform the way you
work out so no longer do you need to be
using these bands
under the table at work like i do that
you guys don't know about
hotels or on an airplane or in
restaurants while we're eating
goodbye i love hydro so much what about
you em
i've been loving it wait weren't you
guys using my hydro
the other day in my gym because i heard
some very weird noises i don't know what
was
happening oh god i love my name hydro i
just want to try a new class
what's this pirate class
you want a pirate's workout so you don't
end up with wooden legs
booting arms well paulie has something
to say about that
well let's get these wooden legs are
burning
hydro bro i am
oh be prepared to walk the plank
are you looking for your booty
that's a good point i am getting a
better booty
near it's not a ship for the tenth time
it looked like a ship it's a hydro it's
a state-of-the-art rowing machine
designed to
totally reinvent the way you work out
and it's amazing you'll be walking the
plank for telling me lies like that it'd
be a ship
it's not an idea it's not a ship
it's a workout that uses 86 of your
muscles and it was named one of time
magazine's 2020
best inventions of the year well paulie
and me be thinking it's shit oh my god
and you'll be walking the plank i'm
working on my glutes i'm working on my
core
i don't have time for this go to
hydro.com that's
hydro.com all the cool kids are using it
the rock kevin hart
whitney coming adult men not kids
learn more at hydro.com that's
hydrow.com
okay this is the most important question
do you want to look at my sticker
collection and tell me which ones are
your favorites
yes great i do i knew it
okay all right you just point to the
ones oh you went right to your
look at that whoa that's so oh that's so
weird
this was one of my favorites right here
the hawk on and on fire it's a good one
who did that um i think sean cliver did
clever yeah yeah
um because this was well this was my
official second graphic but most famous
yeah and then came this one and then
came this one but this one
it was like when skating was kind of
dying yeah so
that cliver incredibly consistent yeah
is there can we get a full name on
climber
sean cliver who is still part of the
jackass crew who i just saw
at the jackass still doing great
graphics oh yeah two weeks ago oh i'm
excited about that um so any favorites
uh well i you know i always love santa
cruz and
are there any graphics that you kind of
envy where you're like because pow was
so
kind of structured did you ever look
companies like man i kind of wish i
i loved powell i loved i love their
graphics i mean vcjs
yeah i mean just the directions skulls
and everything i i
do i did enjoy christians because it was
so much more
uh just like pattern visual yeah and i
thought that was cool lester
yeah lesser kasai sims graphics are cool
um but yeah
wow this is you got some how do you feel
towards collectors
as a pro is it you're like oh that's
cute jealous now oh chris miller
those were all free i got him from ed
templeton that's cool that is pretty
cool
it is you are he
wait so that's an interesting thing you
just said about collectors versus pros
and the idea that like why would you
collect when you're doing it like
later pros ver i mean lance has in this
insane horde everyone hears about
yeah but most pros don't like ed doesn't
keep stuff like if you don't know you're
a part of something when you're a part
it's like when people talk about the
comedy store and podcasts and stuff
like are you collecting all that i'm
like no like do you i gave away all my
trophies like i gave them away the day
of you know yeah
to a kid oh here oh man
should we try to get it back do you have
any of those i tried like do you have
any of those stickers
of yours of your design do you have like
a few a few
a few i have a box you have a box i just
saw the other day a little box this big
with
a bunch of bones we get stuff in there
can i see it yes
also if you any of you guys have any of
tony hawk's trophies fucking
dm me i will pay you we need them back
he made a mistake of adrenaline so hard
to get
that one was the cost of fortune we we
covered our van in 87
with the side of the van with these one
day because you're on the tour and
you're bored because you're
getting in the van so we had thousands
of these in the back and we were so
sick of like why do we have to be the
ones that throw these out so
we covered the entire side of the van in
these
first demo we did they were all peeled
off these are seven
this has cost 75 now oh my
wow i don't want to know um ooh that's
rare just martinez yeah
that's a good one do you know what's
weird i just i'm on cameo
not so tight how much yeah i'm gonna get
one probably
um by the way is it like there's a
different price for webb and for the
i don't know it's like mine's 250 or 300
depending on how you book it but um
by the way it's such a genius idea that
if someone wants to have you on their
podcast just like oh you can just buy
the questions on cameo and if you buy
enough of them you'll have a podcast
episode i did yes
there was a while ago where i did get
there was some financial thing and i
could tell the guy kept
hey what's your answer to this i was
like is this guy just doing an interview
that he's going to
yeah he sent me maybe like seven or
eight questions and i was like well all
right
pay for each one okay i guess i'll do it
i mean you're
you're doing an episode of my sticker
show right now i don't know if you know
that but
it is there's something so funny about
anyone can have it but i got a
request to wish jesse martinez had a
birthday oh sweet
which was kind of weird that is weird
because i would did you
did you ever skate around him like did
you ever go down to venice and state
that scene
um yeah a couple times but i just he was
on the bones we get for
oh yeah but you'll like this
my door when i was 12 sponsored by dog
town was covered in this sticker right
here
the door to my bedroom and i begged my
parents
to keep that dog when we moved they
wouldn't do it
what happens in your brain when you see
these uh
it takes me back for sure okay i have a
good story
um i my dad used to give me
um a dollar for drinks
at the skate park right i got a dollar
yeah and
these were a quarter right and so
i bought a drink and two going stickers
and i was so
excited too so thirsty because i want
going like going with san diego yeah and
that's who i wanted to be sponsored by
and
you know it's funny that i never
actually did ride for him right um
and then tracker was my sponsor for like
10 years
um kevin stobb sent me that
because i couldn't find it it's
impossible did you buy something from
90.
no but i was like hey i'll buy like i
was like hey man this is a long shot but
do you maybe have the sticker okay so
kevin kevin's the guy that has
everything that's awesome and he does
not allude to that
oh because he was like yeah i got it and
it was at my house like soon no he's got
anything you have here that you're
excited about he's got a pack of them
like this oh that's exciting but he's
like
like doesn't let everyone know yeah or
he just doesn't he never wants to go
through him
kevin you have a gold mine you have like
you have an
ebay store yeah in your house do you
have to get that insured i mean you also
should no he doesn't yeah i don't care
he's just
og thrasher stickers yep yeah that's
pretty good
at templeton yep wow
these are awesome thanks can i
always love toy machine graphics i mean
yeah it is
turtle boy like he was it was i mean
this stuff like
he was so brilliant this toy machine
that is one of the most brilliant
graphics basically you know how people
write
yeah do you have one of those no i don't
i mean i have it i work for toy machine
sometimes i do graphics but i have
hundreds of those because i basically
it's knuckles
it's definitely knuckles so he just
added a bunch
more fingers here that could be toy
machine that's so
funny yeah it's so perfect do you find
though that like part of
kevin's style is so you know
specifically like
like cool and do do you find when new
like young graphics people come in
you're like this is not what we're doing
do you get a
like like visuals wise i i let my our
team
decide to do everything their aesthetics
yeah we're not trying to have like a
comprehensive
theme or anything not usually so it's
just like hey that's what you want to do
let's do it i find myself being like i
want this to look like it was made in
the 90s and we just found it
you know i thought this was always
really cool too yeah that's a lift
uh that is jim phillips did not create
that out of his brain necessarily
it's a very famous like uh 1930s
illustrator they got a lot of stuff from
like the
grosso bat wings and uh the kendall
science guy saw this guy named virgil
finley who died in like 1935
who was a super genius that i think
phillips was just a huge fan of
right yeah and were the stickers to put
to put on the boards obviously but also
to because in dc they'd be all over
stuff when i was a kid you got like one
board a year
you got a board at christmas yeah and
then after a while it was destroyed
so then you got stickers and put them on
the board to keep it looking cool
yeah because the graphics started to get
degenerated over time right right so
stickers were like a way to keep your
stuff looking cool
and kind of acknowledge because you only
got the one board a year so
i get the tony hawk mini but i want
other people to know i like other
companies too so like
you're like i got an album like i know
what's up they're for your parents to
figure out what to buy
next year look i have a bones brigade
membership card but i'm not a cult
it's funny though when you say that
because i've seen boards come up on
ebay or on sites and they're and they're
like this was written
tony hawk's board and i'm like you guys
that has a
gotcha sticker on it yeah and santa cruz
like
i don't think i'd be putting a no a
competitor's
ten foot boneless stubbies stubbies at
the time
tracker what stubbies were these weird
clothes he knows my history
stubby's what do you think's worse
stubbies or jimmies
ah well in worse in what way like
wearable jimmies
were weird to wear let me see
the whole loose fitting look yeah
um stubbies was funny because i actually
approached them to be sponsored
because i was looking for a clothing
sponsor at the time and they were
starting to do stuff in the u.s but what
i didn't realize is that stubbies were
only known
as rugby shorts in australia so
super short shorts yeah that was their
thing they were like the dolphin shorts
of australia
and they were starting to make surf
oriented clothes and so i went
and i called them like cold call i was
maybe 18 or something
hey do you want to sponsor a
skateboarder yeah
and then i convinced them to make shorts
that were almost to the knee
but do you understand what you're saying
like it would never occur
to me to go like hey gucci whitney
cummings here
i haven't made it it wasn't quite a
gucci phone call but but you know what i
mean the fact that you're picking up the
phone going like i can
i'm gonna try it like what like i'm
fascinated by the fact that the um the
most
uh impossible things to achieve you
actually have the least amount of
competition because so few people even
attempt it
yeah so it's like the idea it's like no
one else was calling that
is my guess and just the idea of just
going like what i'm going to lose a
minute and what being fair what are they
going to say no
i don't i already don't have shorts they
say no exactly yeah
that was that was the attitude for sure
it was like what do i get to lose yeah
but it's like that is such a
like it like that is such a fascinating
component i think to like winners going
like oh yeah one more note what's one
more note today i mean that's
literally how i've gotten my career is
like i just have such a high tolerance
for the word no and when i hear
no i have this weird kink that it's like
well i want one no closer to here yes
like that's gonna be such a cool talk
show story i'm gonna be like they said
no to me like 20 times i just kept
calling
like i picture it as a talk show story
why am i getting rejected at that time i
approached quicksilver first
because quicksilver was starting to get
into skate stuff kinda but they weren't
officially sponsoring
skaters and i went to them and i said
hey you know what do you want to do like
some sort of partnership or agreement
and they're like nah
really yeah i remember it vividly
because it was like in slow-mo like
no thanks because it was at a trade show
back yeah the asr was the thing and so i
and so i went oh okay and then i think i
went to the subbies booth from there
whoa and the guy who just got put in
charge of the us
stubbies was like yeah i heard of you
let's talk
is there like a relation because the the
skateboarding scene that i like
witnesses like a
you know youngster was very um sort of
hand in hand with like the graffiti
scene in dc
and there was like a big need to like
leave a mark
let you know people know you were there
and to like
make a point like publicly that like we
were here
and you know like i guess what i'm
asking is like how
and now when i think of like skaters now
and like twitter and communicating like
how big
of a um deal is it to like be
seen or heard or like leave a mark do
you know what i'm saying is it part
i think it's well not necessarily in the
tagging sense
it's more that what did you do at that
spot yeah you shut the spot down got it
got it got it
and so it's like he did an nbd
at this kinked rail yeah but nbd has
never been done
and that's that's your mark that's
fascinating and if someone else does
that
they're kind of marked as a dick so it's
our like mic drop it's you're like
pissing on your territory like i
own this place yeah yeah it's just like
why'd you do that that other dude did
that same thing
that's all i got who shut down the most
spot like there's all stories of like
tom penny just shutting down
streets wait so if someone does a trick
on a corner or no one else is allowed to
do it if they film it and post it
ah at this point it's like first it's
not good luck to do that sure but it
i don't care like i know but i'm
fascinated by like the inside
for sure for sure for the hardcore
street
follower skater that's a thing where
it's just like
what you should have done something else
because comics like
my whole last special was about robots
if someone's next special had was all it
would just be like
like so we're getting into the weeds
here but like sunset car wash
yeah right you've seen the sunset car
wash it's on the way to the comedy store
right
yes it's just of course the course
they're huge for the coffee bean yeah i
know exactly
people all the way off the roof into the
bank and now
that has been done a few times yeah um
not by many i mean talking about like a
handful so now
it's like what trick can you do into the
bank yeah and now there's been
three tricks that got kick-flipped into
it kick flipped into it
milton martinez yeah um and then that
guy recently did the 270.
yeah um and i think there's one other
thing maybe that happened i don't know
i just remembered grecco someone lost a
knee
i mean right that those those videos
that footage is
but but it's like no one's going there
just to
all into it yeah not anymore right yeah
and
only three people in the world have ever
done that but that's that's the attitude
of skating it's like
well i'm not going to go there and do
something that's already been done it's
like but if you did that that would be
amazing it's so dangerous so gnarly i
went up there looked out i was like
hell no no it's not even it's it's like
that it's not even like a 45 degree
sending you into sunset boulevard on
your stomach for sure
but so this is my other question for you
is like do you kind of also have to be
like a
medic yeah yeah i talked about that
actually we talked about on our on our
podcast how we
have these little hacks that we do like
i've done
my own stitches and you kind of know
like oh
that's probably more of a ligament thing
or that's more of a bone thing and
you can self-assess as well and and it
is and
i mean i guess it's advantageous to have
kids because
i can tell immediately if this is going
to be a serious hospital thing or based
on the way they cry or the way they
just how it looks how it feels what's
going on with it yeah and uh
it is weird you just get thrown in by
default
into your own sort of medical
i don't want to say expertise but
experience but in how much of it is just
like
lock st like um uh gut
of like since i work with my body so
much i know what he did i know what this
needs and how much of it is just like
i've been doing this for so long i've
seen so many
both for sure you always have to be
prepared to be like a civil war surgeon
at any moment if you're going to be i
did uh i was at the skate park i was
actually doing this giveaway to
a um concert festival in san diego where
we were going to be skating and so i did
a little thing like
tweeted out hey i'll be at the skate
park first 100 people to say what's up
i'll give you tickets to the show
so i get to the skate park and almost
immediately
i fell in this bowl i was just kind of
warming up i did a lip slide my front
foot came off
fell and hit my my temple but my helmet
i hit and then my helmet slid up and
then i hit again and so i split my
eyebrow open
and it was it was immediately like
oh fuck i'm going to need stitches or
i'm going to need to you know
to tape like i have the usually i carry
stereo strips with me which keeps me
yes your skin closed and so
and and i just tweeted this out people
are just arriving
hey guys this is what i learned
is that people don't care if there's
blood
coming out of your head no they want
their tickets they want
selfies and they want autographs yeah
and there was only one person that even
was like are you okay
yeah if you fainted right now i'm
getting a picture
i i encountered at least i encountered
at least 40 people
on my way to my car and only one was
like are you are you all right
but i do think you are there i got the
last picture of tony hawk you guys but
here's what i'll say
i'm fascinated by people that are as
famous as you at something
and how they perceive the world because
the world is so affected by their
presence that they can never have any
accurate understanding of what the world
is even like
so because you can ev your presence
affects people so so i i i
have i've tried maybe three times
actually stressed out about what i was
gonna like wear on a podcast
or in a meeting with anyone one was
michael patrick king because he created
sex in the city and i like put on a tutu
to meet him
and then i and then we went to all these
pitch meetings and i realized every
woman was wearing like a ball gown to
the meetings and i was like i know you
you never fucking just oh it's cause
he's here
you're dressing up because he's a
fashion icon it's like for you i was
like
do i wear my old thrasher shirt no it's
too on the nose like i'm gonna wear my
first
like i was like so stressed out and i
was like oh my god he must
think that everyone just has cool shirts
all the time but they have one cool
shirt
that they're only wearing because you're
impressed that you this uh what the
shirt you're wearing is actually
my son's graphic so yeah
because it's got his sunglasses yes i
was gonna wear yours that would just be
two i don't want to be out of nowhere
guess what you can't get it i don't want
the guests that i want on really that
was not like becoming a fan
it wasn't easy they didn't make a lot of
money yeah they didn't make a lot of
those it's hard to get the stickers too
yeah this is for i mean kevin
has procured this right now i'm very
impressed um do old skaters ever come up
to you and are like
i was pretty good when i was like 12 and
you're like no you weren't like
i could have if you were you would have
kept you know you're like i actually was
pretty good
it's i i believe yeah
[Music]
because it is like people come up to
comics like yeah i used to do some like
community theater but uh
you know went to law school and said
you're like are you implying that you
could have done this
had you just kept at it maybe i feel
like when you meet people you see a lot
of brand new pair of vans well they're
like i'm meeting tony hawk better put on
these skateboards
i've never noticed that i've never
thought that someone
dressed the part to come meet me like
you know that no one's asking you how
you are
even though your face is bleeding
because they they they want to be cool
and not like know who you are
you know it's like uh i don't know what
it i i think it was just they were
caught in the moment it was just like
hey man tony tweedy's gonna go under and
let's go meet him like oh there he is
and it was it was never like
oh he got fucked up hey there's a lot of
blood on your face and the funny thing
is i went to a pharmacy straight from
there to go buy steri strips and to go
buy
alcohol and to clean and stuff and i'm
in line with
this like i'm in line with a hospital
supply
of gear and the dude that was checking
me out was like
hey tony yo man can i get a selfie and
he
stopped scanning my items to come around
and shoot us i was like
yeah but that's why i'm here but also
you've only proven that you're going to
be
just fine this is your fault no one's
like oh we need to help tony hawk he
seems like a pretty uh
fragile guy they're like oh it's only
some blood coming out of the eyeball
this is actually i guess it comes with
the territory yeah it's part of my job
there's something interesting about like
the way people react to you you have no
idea because they're reacting to you
like i wouldn't think i'm cool i don't
want because everyone thinks they have a
shot at being your friend myself
included
i want him to bleed to death they were
like like
in their mind that that's gonna go hey
dude are you okay and you're like no
it's pretty bad like then what
they're like all right bye do you want
to call them because you are like
symbolic
to a super age group of especially dudes
like you've been famous to me since i
was
10. right so like you're a human
obviously but also you're this idea of
skateboarding and like the most famous
game you've been the most famous
skateboarder in the world for like 20
years
and that's it it's fucking weird dude
you know it's weird
and like do you have a sense of that
responsibility kind of
i i have come to embrace that and come
to terms with that in recent years
yeah um i used to what are your final
words before your son eclipses you in
fame
oh please do it faster what's my final
words bring it on
um no but i did i did kind of come to
understand that i have
this reach and this voice that could
affect change and it could also
uh promote skateboarding in a way that
maybe others couldn't
yeah and i've come to
to advocate to to be an advocate for
skating in general
yeah and i understand that and and i
don't take it lightly and i i love doing
it like i really do i love i enjoy
talking about skating and how it can be
so great for kids of any background for
mental health for their sense of self
confidence their sense of self-esteem
their community and so that's that's
what i do
now yeah i feel like that's more my role
than anything which is like so
you know to be sort of um uh uh father
figure whatever to like misfits to me
there's no more honorable
sort of thing to do and um and i was
listening to your podcast and like i i
was kind of like i'm like this is just
gonna make me feel stupid like i don't
know that much or like i can't
understand what's going on because
everything was so relatable like you
know when chris rock always says the
more specific you are the more universal
you are like when you
are getting into like granular like
super like geeked out
esoteric skater stuff yeah i can even be
like oh that's like that time i dated
that guy and i kept
calling and i kept calling and it didn't
work and i just had to do i mean like
everything becomes a metaphor for
something else
because it's just about toiling and
overcoming adversity and not giving up
yeah i mean that's that's what you know
when people say what did skating prepare
you for like everything yeah
and especially disappointment and and
perseverance
more than anything and sometimes you can
do everything fucking right and then
just something dumb
like they don't catch it on camera and
you're like even though i've controlled
everything in my
ability to make this perfect i can't
control other people's behavior
yeah yeah exactly and and you just learn
to
accept it too like i just can't there's
not some crushing defeat now
where you build up something especially
when you're young
that it means everything when you don't
get it you don't know what to do with
yourself and and so you realize
especially later it's just like yeah it
didn't work and also i think that
there's something of like when
when something when a skill requires
that much immersion and
is so all-consuming it took me so long
to learn sometimes the best thing you
can do is walk away and do something
else
does that make any sense absolutely yeah
nothing i can do is stop and just like
take a nap and and be a person like for
art to imitate life you have to have a
life it's like the best thing i can do
to be a comedian right now is to just go
to the mall and go to things remembered
and buy a friend
like it has nothing to do with comedy i
just have to go have a life things
remember do you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
by 6 30. i'm going to lose my bcbg is
going to hear about it if journeys
is not open in topanga anymore i'm going
to flip
my shit but it is like sometimes like
the best
visionaries and thinkers and athletes
like sometimes it just takes doing
something like really simple
to just being uh like to step up just
bring it back
yeah to just recenter for sure can i ask
one last question and that means i have
like three more but i'm gonna do my best
because you have to get out of here and
i respect you and so i'm not gonna keep
you late like i normally do everyone
else
um uh but can you can i just ask you
something about because i was talking to
kevin before this to make sure i didn't
totally embarrass myself
like me being from like dc seeing some
of the virginia like richmond like sort
of
skate which is a lot of dc like and then
i when i meet people from that new york
scene it's like
totally different from that time and
then san diego in san francisco
are like total like i was like oh yeah
skaters like didn't do drugs were
straight edge and they're like
san francisco was like what like you
what is the d can i just i
hope without getting anyone into trouble
and i'm happy to take the
i'm sure i will take the blame uh of
like what is each
scene's kind of
stereotype's the wrong word but like
theme vibe and what does that say about
the country and the way
that it and i think that that a lot of
that has been
washed away with the how prolific social
media is and the speed of information
and so now
skaters i can't say there's just one
type of skater in any certain
area um but for sure
like new york was like hardcore
street and you had to be rough and tough
because you had to deal with cops with
crackheads with
you know you to skate anywhere traffic
traffic you're dealing with all kinds of
different elements terrible asphalt
like terrible asphalt yeah you had to be
totally just
rough and tumble like you had to you had
to be committed to it and they were a
little more
harder edge like their attitude was like
fuck it this is our
nyc five boroughs yeah yeah and so
you know it's a little more mellow in
san diego because it's like we got skate
parks we got the surf yeah yeah
you know and so we didn't have those
challenges
and so it breeds a different type of
attitude interesting um and so
dc was yeah i mean it was punk it was
hardcore but it was like
but you know what's interesting about
because i'm because there is such a i'm
obsessed with like counter the things
that become counter culture and
why and like why the dc scene that i um
uh hung out in uh uh
was straight edge because it usually
it's a reaction to whatever the
authority's doing i mean this was a time
where the our mayor
mary berry did crack and we reelected
him so it's like the authority figures
are doing drugs let's
not do drugs that's the punk rock shit
to do is to not do crack
yeah well i think a big part of that too
was in makai
a minor threat was leading the charge
and people were
yeah they were in they were all in i
mean he's awesome he's still there yeah
still in the same house seriously
discord house that's correct we went and
visited the discord house my wife and i
because it's so iconic obviously and and
he invited us and my
and he has this insane archive of
cassette tapes and videos and shows and
and
scenes and it's all just it's all like
paper and it's all stacked tightly and
my wife was like
if there's a fire there's a fire like
the history of punk rock is gone so she
bought him a fire extinguisher and sent
it to him
[Music]
by the way this is i i'm obsessed with
the woman how do i take care of mine
how can i care for her the fact that
she's like punk history is in my hands
but you can you can see we have a photo
with with ian and his skateboard
that's on the salad days cover wow um
on his porch we we posed on his porch
for the most
you know that's iconic that's insane
that's it that's insane can i ask you
about san francisco because and how does
the terrain affect the person like
of uh san francisco san francisco is is
uh
it's a different vibe obviously but
there was there was a stronger skate
scene
through the years because some of the um
companies were
based there including thrasher um and
and nhs santa cruz everyone but um
people are very accustomed to hill
bombing
in san francisco yeah and there's a
whole crew and movement of people that
can
go down the steepest scariest hills
without
without losing control see this is it's
making me realize like because at first
i wanted to ask you like if you want to
be
a pro skater right now what city do you
move to to be the best
and now you're making me realize like
just whatever
city you're in is just going to develop
you're going to be yeah you're going to
adapt to
what the different but also skate parks
are finally more abundant
and so if you want to be a bowl skater
you could still do it in san francisco
yeah and you couldn't
you couldn't 20 years ago yeah no and
then what about lasting international
when you travel internationally
um it's growing all over and i think
you know once the olympics happen this
month
that's going to raise the profile and
the awareness
much more but i've seen skating in the
most unlikely places like i went to
there's a full thriving skate scene in
ethiopia that i went and skated with
locals there
um i've skated uh there's there's a
skate park
in uganda i haven't been there but there
is and if you look up videos it's
fascinating
wow um can you say something just quick
about how to learn to skate in a war
zone
uh yeah well that was so that
documentary on skadastan which is a
group that
that provide that does skateboard
facilities and education like literal
education
um in some of the craziest areas in
their most famous
is in kabul afghanistan and um they did
a documentary on some girls there
was how to skate in a war zone if you're
a girl learn to skate how to learn how
to learn to skate in a war zone if
you're a girl
and it's about these girls that have
found skating stand because they get to
go to school there
and they get to skate and because it's
not considered a sport
they're allowed to skate do us do an
activity that boys also do
because they're not allowed to play
sports yeah so there's this sort of
loophole there
and it's fascinating because these girls
they rip and they're they're dedicated
the most fascinating part of
skateboarding right now is the females
like it's
fascinating because it reminds me of the
90s growing like exponentially they're
so core
they're just trying to rip i just saw um
i was at a i was doing a little
video thing at a skate shop actually um
from before i got here and samaria
brevard just walked in
and it was like this this girl she's
awesome she's like one of the best
street skaters and she just you know
just casually
walks into this skate show where yeah uh
what is that part that one that's right
off santa monica boulevard
uh rip city hmm
is it la skate or something like that
lasko that used to be hot skates in
glendale
i'm fast see i'm fascinated this is
where i do like
i think love to have insight around like
when there's like a new or when
something's becoming bigger for women
right like when people like what's it
like being a community female comment
now i'm like oh i'm so fucking sick of
this question
but here's the thing i will say the
reason it's different now is that we get
to all have different emotional
reactions to things and different
behaviors and it doesn't reflect on
everyone so
when there's a scarcity complex when
there's only a couple female skaters
number one the pressure's on to be the
best at all you can't just be
good you have to be the best or i'll see
i told you they couldn't fucking
you know like when i was first doing
stand-up every time i went up there i
was
very aware that like the way i do right
now affects the way that
it either affirms the stereotypes or i'm
gonna have to change people's minds i
can't just go up and be funny i have to
either change people's minds
or i have to a fur or i'm going to
affirm a negative stereotype that harms
people it's like this is not
like you know what stand up should be
and the same thing i think with skating
is like you know
when you get to just be okay and still
get to get better
and at this in the same timeline as
everyone else so it's like for me as a
female comic i also had to be way better
than i should have been given the amount
of time i had it's like no in two years
i had all of a sudden be really good
just because there were eyes on me
because people were like oh what's the
girl going to do and it was like i just
want to be able to be invisible for like
five years and just get good
yeah but i couldn't and then it was like
oh see the women are funny so well i've
only been doing this for six months like
you know but i think that um there's
also a greater range of like the way
the way women's i'm excited to sort of
see you know the emotional reactions
because
because i've spent so much time going
like you're not allowed to be loud
you're not allowed to be
emotional because people can say you're
crazy you can't like snap at people
like it'll be interesting to watch
because um
anger releases such a big part of it
like what what that looks like because
because lizzy is like i she's so calm
and she's so um hard to shake
yeah yeah that's true and and for well
it but but it
like i said you can't you there's no way
to to stereotype
yeah who skates now and and especially
in the women
they come from all different backgrounds
and um
you know like leticia buffoni is
probably one of the favorites of the
street comes from brazil and yeah and
she has a different look and
and um and then there's
scrappy girls that came you know that
fought their way out
to try to get recognized and they're
going to be olympians
that's amazing and i'm just fucking so
psyched i saw this
uh did you see the video of the little
girl skating in the tutu
yeah oh theresa so raisa i would say
raisa
is probably one of the absolute
favorites to win
the olympics and that was how she got
recognized was doing a heelflip in a
tutu yeah you reposted that video and it
went completely nuts
yeah and i mean now she's have you seen
her she rips
like she absolutely better than i than i
ever i'm not even close
yeah like there was never a change she
was like a machine of
of uh consistency and just
one trick after the other dangerous
stuff and it's just like oh she's got it
that's because that to me is as soon as
like i know this is like fashion is not
my strong suit like not something i'm
super interested in but i
am super interested in how fashion
reflects like what's going on in terms
of
i didn't feel like i was really able to
be an authentic comedian until i was
able to like wear my hair down on stage
because i used to go on me like you have
to kind of look like a boy
you have to wear a hoodie you have to
wear a backpack like when when you're
allowed to be
feminine yeah in a in a male dominate
whatever feminine means
that's gonna get me canceled but
whatever when you're allowed to just um
express yourself however the fuck it is
and not have to go like i have to dress
like one of the guys i have to do tricks
like that
but it's so much it's so much more
welcome too now because there's
other little girls that want to get into
it and they want to be their own their
own person yeah and they don't want to
have to fit into some
whatever because because that's that's
the only way that you're going to be
accepted yeah because it's also just
optics-wise it just like always looked
like it was just for the guys and even
if you are a girl you have to kind of
act like the guys that's what i did
that's what i grew and then i see like
catherine ryan and natasha and i see
these female comics that are in like
dresses and like gloves and i'm like i
didn't think that was
an option because we were already trying
to make people forget that we were women
like why are you reminding them the new
group the kind of the new people that
are
getting finally some attention and
skating are the most like the queer
skaters and there's a bunch of
trans skaters like it's awesome
skating you know it's it's
unique but it's also there's a lot of
similarity and now it's like
it's getting unique again like there's
so many different types yeah
yeah you're just like oh everyone's
doing this and it's awesome okay i am
these very awkwardly anyway
i did watch tony hawk's master class in
skateboarding
oh thank you i am not a master at
skateboarding yet but i believe i have
the mental tools and the understanding
for if
i ever want to be one i'm prepared i'm
glad it helps
it did like but now that we're friends
you can just reach out to me
hey so directly listen can you imagine
like in real time
listen i can't get i'm in my driveway i
can't get the board to flip
i'm really trying to shrop a grind can
you help me as long as
you won't call me to be like hey i'm
doing this event tonight do you have
like a joke like
that's what a lot of times when i think
people of different fields meet and
they're like oh let's be friends i'm
like i'd love to be friends with you and
they'll just be like hey i'm about to
like go on stage at the kennedy center
can you like write a joke for me i don't
know no no my ask is going to be
much deeper mine's going to be now that
we are going into
public events again yeah fundraising um
you want me to come tell dick jokes for
your uh child school
mine would be a little more curated and
it would be more like
hey come have dinner and have a private
show
from wit performance want me to just go
on dates you want me to just be a
prostitute
come have dinner with me no no pay me no
it would be a high
high-end dinner and then you you could
perform for
half hour this still sounds really
dangerous
this still sounds like a trap sort of
shit
no but i don't figure out a way to
present it i will do it how about that
regardless of whether it's a chair
you're not if that's just your version
of hanging out
i'll do that i don't put people on a
spot like that even if i get put on the
spot like that all the time for our
first time hanging out and you're like
so are you gonna
do you want to go up now or wait i have
to do stand up for you guys i do have a
funny story though when you said it
would be for kids our very first charity
event we ever did was called stand up
for skate parks
and it was at the bowling alley in la i
don't know if it's still there
lucky strike lucky strike or not
or pins
[Music]
okay so it was it was at pins and um
uh and it was we didn't know what we
were doing we're just trying to
raise money so we had like yeah yeah
circus rides out in the parking lot we
had a vert ramp in the parking lot
and we had i don't know david spade
doing stand up
and what we realized that is all these
kids with families
yeah no no he performed
in the bowl in the alley oh my gosh so
awkward i mean i so thankfully did it
but but it was so awkward and i could
see him
by the way still the biggest break of
his life i could still see jokes coming
to him where he's like oh this is not
you know
this is not the audience you're like hey
man member police academy we're cool
remember when we remember that we're
good right you did it and flake 182
played
on the lanes the new thing i have whoa
the new thing i have learned to do is go
okay i'm invited to host
happened to me the other night host a
thing i go who's that who's the audience
they're gonna it's all like adult
you know they never know the answer so
then i prepare for a couple iterations
of it and if there's kids in the
audience which there always are
at these school functions i'll go like
you know what you guys i'll do the sex
talk so you don't have to you know what
i mean
and that's what i'm turning into i'm
like i'm gonna let me take this off your
shoulders
i'll just do this and then and then i
also will do things
to make parents have to get annoying
questions from their kids over the
weekend
so i'll just ask your mom about that and
they're like fuck you my kid won't stop
asking me what official it is
so it's just like you have to just more
lean into it that way because those
fundraisers are
always like super weird and awkward but
we have to do them and there's a way to
do them that is like
right but yeah i i sense that if we we
would do it we would embrace
whatever it is you wanted yeah that be
comedians on skate
i honestly think you should do a
comedian skate competition
in skaters doing stand-up it's
i would pay way more money to see that i
mean i wrote ed some jokes for his hall
of fame speech he did pretty good
like he delivered him okay i think a lot
of skaters can deliver stuff
yeah it's about timing i mean it is a
similar sure comedian bodies do not
perform athletically
terribly well i just wouldn't want to be
responsible for someone's rolled ankle
or
broken arrest they would be thrilled
yeah in front of you they wouldn't cop
i'm good like no one's going to get off
there's something funny to me that
everyone that's ever talked to you at a
park is injured but didn't want you to
know so everyone's like
it's really good jesus you're like no
one shakes my hand
yeah it's like because it's broken
they're all hanging by a threat
everyone's wincing
but uh but there is yeah there is and
the last thing i'll say is because you
have to believe
um did you ever see fred armisen did a
special just for drummers yeah
comedy for drummers no i didn't see it
dude it is so funny it's so good
yeah half of the stuff most people
wouldn't get if they don't know about
but it's still funny and you're not even
sure why but doing like the audience
had to drive we'll write this for you
only drummers were allowed in the
audience
it was tremendous like if you did a just
comedy for skaters
i mean kevin and i could write it for
you in 20 minutes and it's just skaters
and then the proceeds go to whatever
like it would just be so
fucking funny you have to watch comedy
for drummers i will i will i actually
saw the the last time i saw a devo play
fred armisen was their drummer he can
play the drums for real
it's really something yeah he's unreal
but and they put him kind of
hidden on the stage i was like why
aren't they they're just we don't want
the distraction it's like tom lennon's
in like a morrissey cover band
he's in whatever the biggest smith's
cover band when they say are we not men
we are devo is he allowed to shout it
i wonder if he's just a guest drummer
he's like just a woman
yeah he'd probably shout it way too long
today
we are devo for the next 20 minutes god
damn it we are tempted
that's so fascinating to me the idea
that he screams
if you yell it we'll sue the shit out
about that was that
that at that particular concert when
they asked him to drum for them
they had already booked it he had
already bought tickets
that's true that was so funny because
he's a debo fan he bought tickets to the
show and they're like come on jeremy's
like
i'm already going to be there oh totally
do you want to i'll give you a ride
and he's like but do i still get to sit
in my seat after because i just deserve
scenes i got really good seats no thanks
but also the last thing is that he goes
on stage and he's drumming and he'll
like do a little he'll be like
all the drummers in north carolina go
through and everyone goes crazy because
it's like some inside joke
it's so specific it's amazing there's
some jokes in it that are so weird and
good
i just it's great you're like only my
friends would get this but it's gonna be
so massive
i mean okay you have to go to torrance
for some reason i do
i'm sorry i end these awkwardly uh
uh your podcast is on the wall platform
no i'm not even done yet
that's that wasn't even as awkward as
it's gonna be oh awkward and then yes
and we're going to
can you silence don't ride elephants i
love you guys
uh hawk versus wolf don't ride elephants
elephants don't write elephants this
this podcast is so
soothing and inspiring and activating
and it was so cool to listen to y'all's
report and also
as you're signing cause i know you have
to go um what if i just making this
tuesday oh my god
he signs it i won't sell it i promise
it's bad
but also the way you talk about like
your radio show and like the ups and
downs of that and the sort of like as
thanks man you know people that do we do
now we have to have all these other
skills in addition like i'm a pro skater
now i have to like
be able to you know have a radio show
and book guests and like how even when
you're
you know you're at the top of your game
you're still having to do everything
yourself
yeah it was so cool to hear that because
there's many times where like
there's there's many times where i am
like
why i'm at a certain level i should be
able to have people do this for me it's
like it never ends
you're always doing it for yourself even
when you're
i embrace it and you're
but it's such a waste frozen in time
what's better education
that for anyone that wants to be a
winner than going oh yeah i'm always
have to do it myself i'm not gonna let
any wait for anyone
i love you guys
[Music]
you